und vor ort für uns ist mein kollege
erhard scherfer an denen ich nun über
gebe denn er hat mehr
danke tina da ja es ist der zweitgrößte
haushalt in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik ist auch die zweithöchste
neuverschuldung in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik mit fast 140 milliarden
euro und wer weiß was noch kommt in
diesen zeiten von corona von ukraine
krieg von klimawandel und inflation also
alles noch nicht abzusehen so richtig
und außerdem gibt es da noch den
sonderposten bundeswehr mit 100
milliarden möglichen neuen schulden das
ist ja noch nicht ausgemacht sondern es
geht hier in erster linie mal um
kreditermächtigung also ein
bundeshaushalt der vergleichsweise spät
verabschiedet wird das hat mit dem
regierungswechsel zu tun bislang haben
die ministerium mit einer vorläufigen
haushaltsplanung gearbeitet demnächst
können sie dann auch richtig das geld
ausgeben was ihnen zugestanden wird
durch den deutschen bundestag und
gleichwohl ist es ein haushalt mit
unglaublich vielen unbekannten ich habe
die stichworte am anfang schon gesagt
also durchaus wert auch im vorfeld schon
weil über das zu sprechen was uns hier
die nächsten vier tage erwartet ich
freue mich dass bei uns in gesine
lötzsch die stellvertretende vorsitzende
der linksfraktion und
haushaltspolitische sprecherin und
vorsitzende im haushaltsausschuss ist ja
auch schon mal gewesen und ich freue
mich dass christian dürr bei uns ist ja
vorsitzende der fdp-fraktion auto gegen
einen schönen guten morgen vorbei direkt
mal bei ihnen an ausgerechnet die fdp
und ihr bundesfinanzminister haben die
zweit größte neuverschuldung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
mitzuverantworten früher wurden
finanzminister einmal sparkommissare
genannt
huldigten der schwarzen null das tun sie
im prinzip auch aber jetzt wird ihr
finanzminister schon schulden der
lindener genannt geht dass sie in diesen
zeiten nicht anders mit so vielen
schulden dann muss das ins rechte licht
rücken glaube ich dieser haushalt ist
ein auftakt für den haushalt 2023 den
wir schon in wenigen wochen nach der
parlamentarischen sommerpause beraten
werden und das ist ein haushalt wo die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten werden
was diesen haushalt betrifft herr
schärfer machen war 100 milliarden euro
weniger schulden als die große koalition
und reduzieren die ausgaben um 7 70
milliarden euro daran sehen sie schon
die richtung aber auf den haushalt auf
den ich mich persönlich richtig voll ist
der kommende da wird die schuldenbremse
wieder eingehalten es kommt hat
bekanntermaßen immer auf die perspektive
an ändert aber nichts daran dass es der
zweithöchste
der zweitgrößte haushalt ist die
zweitgrößte neuverschuldung auch es gibt
frauen in diesem haushalt viele punkte
wo sie sagen müssten eigentlich ja
beispielsweise entlastungspaket
zuschüsse für familien mit kindern es
gibt mehr zuschüsse für die
rentenversicherung trotzdem sind sie
nicht zufrieden warum ich kann auch gar
nicht zufrieden sein weil ich sehe dass
es natürlich zuschüsse gibt die reichen
aber bei weitem nicht aus wir haben
jetzt eine inflation von 7,9 prozent und
alles was an zuschüssen gewährt wird
wird damit schon völlig aufgefressen
also brauchen wir andere maßnahmen
ersten wir sind gegen eine hohe
neuverschuldung und dafür brauchen wir
an einnahmen also es gibt ja zum
beispiel in italien jetzt diese über
gewinnen steuer da sagen wir das
brauchen wir auch bei uns hier in der
bundesrepublik denn wir haben ja die
paradoxe situation dass zum beispiel die
anzahl der einkommensmillionäre
gestiegen ist und dass viele doch große
gewinne machen in der krise und auf der
anderen seite viele menschen verarmen
und viele große projekte der ampel
koalition sind überhaupt noch nicht
angegangen worden zum beispiel die
kindergrundsicherung zum beispiel das
bürgergeld und wenn ich jetzt höre im
kommenden jahr soll die schuldenbremse
wieder ziehen dann sind diese projekte
alle nur finanzierbar wenn man wirklich
die reichen zur kasse bittet ganz kurz
mal zwischendurch weil sie am anfang
ihrer antwort gesagt haben wir sind
gegen eine so hohe neuverschuldung aber
generell gegen schulden sind sie
eigentlich nicht oder haben sie da ihre
position als linke gegen die
schuldenbremse ist ein ökonomischer
irrweg da sie ja inzwischen alles
verstanden dass natürlich alle aber
bewusst sich natürlich fragen ist es
nötig so viele schulden zu machen oder
das ist nicht viel wichtiger die
einnahmen zu stärken und wir sagen wir
brauchen vermögensabgaben wir brauchen
ein gerechtes steuersystem und keine
steuererleichterungen für reiche da sind
wir natürlich auf der ganz anderen seite
die fdp hat ja völlig andere vorstellung
als wir deswegen haben sie beide ja auch
eingeladen weil wir unterschiedliche
positionen hören wollen und auch gucken
wie unterschiedlich man eine bestimmte
position probleme auch rangehen kann mit
welchen lösungen wollen sie direkt dazu
ja sehr gerne zur schuldenbremse habe
ich vorhin was gesagt die werden wir
bekommen ja wieder einhalten
direkt an der stelle auch noch mal
direkt nach irgendwie was macht sie da
so sicher sie können doch überhaupt
nicht absehen wie die wie die
einnahmeentwicklung wird sie können
überhaupt nicht absehen wie die ausgaben
werden sie das habe ich will ihnen ein
beispiel sagen weil wir das gegenteil
tun dessen was frau lötzsch gerade
vorgeschlagen hat sie werden mich nicht
die steuern erhöhen ein bundeshaushalt
ist dann solide wenn die wirtschaft
wieder brummt und da müssen wir
hinkommen dass arbeitsplätze wieder
geschaffen werden in deutschland nur
wenn die wirtschaft insgesamt
funktioniert funktioniert auch die
einnahmen das macht man nicht indem man
die steuerlast erhöht sondern dem man
beispielsweise entlastet das tun wir
gerade wir entlasten die menschen in
deutschland übrigens gerade kleine und
mittlere einkommen in höhe von 37
milliarden euro bei der einkommenssteuer
sogar dauerhaft nicht nur für dieses
jahr über tank rabatt haben wir schon
gesprochen in den letzten wochen also
all die dinge tun wir für kleine und
mittlere einkommen dass es sich lohnt zu
arbeiten und nur dann ist ein haushalt
solide also ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
was die schuldenbremse betrifft und
würde ausdrücklich zum gegenteil dessen
raten was frau lötzsch gerade gesagt hat
nicht steuererhöhungen sind das gebot
der zeit sondern steuerentlastung sind
das gebot der zeit die frage ist immer
steuererhöhungen für wen und ich habe ja
schon das beispiel italien genannt da
haben wir also diese über gewinn steuer
warum sollten wir uns nicht an diesem
beispiel orientieren und wir haben ganz
eindeutig krisen gewinnerinnen und
krisengewinner wir haben diesen fehler
des tanks rabatz was eine
steuerermäßigung ist dann müsste man
ganz anders rangehen die große
energiekonzerne profitieren im
augenblick ungeheuer von der situation
und es gibt in zum beispiel in portugal
gibt es eine preisregulierung eines
preises grenze eine höchstgrenze die
festgesetzten oder das wäre der richtige
weg alles länder die weniger
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sind als
deutschland das müsste frau laut stadt
noch hinzufügen das bedeutet auch
geringere einkommen im durchschnitt und
so weiter und so fort das kauft man sich
alles mit ein wenn man die steuerpolitik
machen würde die die linken dort
vorschlagen deswegen rate ich
ausdrücklich zu wachstum und zu
wirtschaftlichem erfolg dann geht es
auch den kleinen und mittleren einkommen
besser und einsatz der schärfer wenn ich
das sagen darf zu über gewinn steuer
über gewinne aus sicht der linken haben
dann zur zeit in den letzten monaten
auch die betreiber von erneuerbaren
energien anlagen gemacht wenn wir die
jetzt zusätzlich belastet obwohl wir
brauchen für die co2 neutralität wäre es
genau der falsche anreiz über gewinn
steuer ist ein bass wurde wenn ich das
mal so neudeutsch sagen darf was mein
sind also ein alters das wird immer in
den raum geworfen nach dem motto hilf
total super ist aber nicht der fall ist
strem kompliziert denn diese über
gewinne die müssten ja definiert werden
also war wann ist ein gewinn ein
ungerechtfertigter über gewinn macht das
steuersystem extrem kompliziert ich
rechne dort nicht mit einnahmen und
nochmal im gegenteil wir brauchen der
wirtschaft die wächst und die
investieren kann das macht man nicht
durch steuern und ich habe damals so
eine frage zu einem sogenannten was wo
hatte nämlich nicht immer irgendwo ihr
morgen die stunde der wahrheit dann
beginnt oder sagen wir mal die tage der
wahrheit weil man kann ja morgen noch
nicht wirklich sagen ob es so
funktioniert aber alles sieht danach aus
dass die einzigen die tatsächlich davon
profitieren die mineralölkonzerne zu
sein scheinen und nicht die die
autofahrerinnen und autofahrer denn der
preis scheint sich ja nicht tatsächlich
irgendwie zu reduzieren also ich bin
dankbar dass helm und das ist in
deutschland der chef des
bundeskartellamtes sich gestern geäußert
hat und gesagt hat er wird genau hin
kugelig erwartet übrigens gleiches von
robert habeck als zuständigen
bundeswirtschaftsminister für diesen
bereich um den tank rabatt muss man
eines sagen 60 prozent der menschen in
deutschland wohnen im ländlichen raum so
wie ich kommen beispielsweise aus
niedersachsen ich habe manchmal das
gefühl dass diese debatte um den tank
rabatt die ja gerade die pendlerinnen
und pendler über drei monate entlasten
soll das ist so ein bisschen aus sicht
der jenige führt wird die in berlin mit
der u bahn zur verfügung aber nicht alle
die frage ist eine andere die frage ist
ja tatsächlich die 60 prozent die sie
angesprochen haben davon profitieren
oder wandels ob es andere sind genau das
kartellamt wird genau darauf achten
deswegen bin ich herrn und den
präsidenten des kartellamtes sehr sehr
dankbar erwartet gleiches von robert
habeck dass dieses geld also diese
entlastung bei der benzinsteuer bei der
dieselsteuer das ist tatsächlich bei den
pendlerinnen und pendlern ankommen ja
also bei aller achtung vor dem
bundeskartellamt das ist natürlich in
dieser frage absolut ein zahnloser tiger
denn das bundeskartellamt wird ja erst
im nachgang tätig und bewerteten dinge
die abgelaufen sind und was wir brauchen
ist wirklich eine festsetzung der preise
und wir hatten ja auch preis
genehmigungen in deutschland für
energiepreise bis zum jahr 2005
abgeschafft wurde also das ist ja nicht
alles irgendwie vor 100 jahren gewesen
oder so sondern in einer sehr sehr
kurzen vergangenheit und wir müssen
bestimmten regularien zu gewähren und
die ideologie der fdp der markt regelt
alles und reguliert alles hat sich ja
nicht als erfolgreich erwiesen das sehen
wir jetzt in den krisen besonders ich
dachte das ganz kurz sagen hersteller
ich kenne kein einziges land der welt in
dem planwirtschaftlich die ideen von
preiswert ist der festsetzung dazu
geführt haben dass gerade kleine
mittlere einkommen davon profitieren im
gegenteil die sind immer ärmer geworden
also die idee planwirtschaftlich
unterwegs zu sein hat in der geschichte
der menschheit nicht funktioniert und
aktuell funktioniert es in keinem land
der welt deswegen bitte weg von diesen
ideen des letzten jahrhunderts lass uns
über innovationen nachdenken ich hoffe
steht ja auch die ampeln gute
stammtischler vor wir waren mal zwei
drei tage ab und gucken wie sich das
entwickelt es bleibt trotzdem ein
eingriff in den markt auch wenn sie
finde ich jedenfalls auch wenn sie da
anderer meinung die steuerbelastung die
vitrinen aus rein griffigen einmal
übrigens eingriff in der man durch die
fdp entlastung bei steuern er nennt es
anders freut sich hat eine andere frage
noch es gibt ein strategiepapier aus dem
finanzministerium unter anderem sind
geplant hilfen für bürgerinnen und
bürger sowie für firmen sie fordern
schnelle hilfe für die bevölkerung
insbesondere für die die in diesen
zeiten dringend unterstützung nötig
haben was ist also falsch an den
überlegungen aus dem finanzministerium
gestern haben wir von finanzminister
lindner gehört er weg ja sogar eine
steuerreform ja aber seine steuerreform
wird natürlich nicht die entlasten denen
es am schlechtesten geht und darum haben
wir viel mehr sympathie für den
vorschlag von hubertus heil den ja
allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht
durchsetzen kann innerhalb der koalition
wir müssen den leuten direkt das geld
geben leute die ein geringes einkommen
haben und eine dadurch relativ geringe
einkommenssteuer oder lohnsteuer
bezahlen profitieren natürlich von
solchen steuer veränderungen viel viel
weniger als menschen mit einem hohen
einkommen und darum sagen wir direkte
entlastung die idee des klima geldes von
hubertus heil war eine gute idee die
ging in die richtige richtung aber die
ist ja gestern schon wieder von
finanzminister lindner platz gemacht
worden und da sieht man natürlich auch
dass diese parteien eigentlich gar nicht
so richtig zusammenpassen klima geld
habe ich auch hier stehen warum kein
sondervermögen armutsbekämpfung
beispielsweise armutsbekämpfung ist das
der beste motor um das zu beseitigen die
armut in deutschland sind neue jobs und
deswegen rate ich auch dringend davon ab
sozusagen jetzt eher arbeitslosigkeit zu
subventionieren an stattdessen sollte
man kleine und mittlere einkommen
entlasten haben im ersten schritt getan
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag den
grundfreibetrag erhöht bei die
pendlerpauschale sprach ich vorhin schon
die haben wir im fokus auch im herbst da
kommt der sogenannte progression bericht
darum geht ja diese debatte also da
sehen wir dass die inflation sich auf
steuersystem auswirkt in dem die leute
ungerechtfertigterweise höhere steuern
zahlen obwohl sie real gar nicht höhere
einkommen haben und da müssen wir die
leute entlassen und deswegen werden
während der ampel darüber reden ich bin
hubertus heil für den impuls dankbar die
instrumente halte ich an der stelle
finde ich ziel führen da haben wir
andere instrumente nämlich im
steuerrecht und das betrifft diejenigen
die jeden morgen aufstehen sehr hart
arbeiten die müssen wir entlasten es ist
doch verrückt dass wir in deutschland
bei 1,4 fachen durchschnittseinkommen
dem 14 fachen des
durchschnittseinkommens schon in
spitzensteuersatz zahlen das sind dinge
an die wir angehen soll also ich muss da
gleich mal einen haken von wegen
arbeitslosigkeit subventionieren das ist
natürlich ich musste mir ein bisschen zu
spitzen kollege derne zynische bemerkung
uns geht es ja auch darum das ist
unheimlich viele menschen gibt die wie
sie es immer so formulieren morgens
aufstehen es gibt eben auch leute die
nachgeschichte arbeiten die waren immer
gegessen die haben dann auch ein recht
darauf tagsüber zu schlafen aber das nur
nebenbei deren einkommen reicht nicht
zum leben und alles was jetzt zusätzlich
kommt durch die inflation durch die
steigenden preise wird aufgefressen und
darum geht es und darum war dieser
vorschlag der direkten entlastung der
leute nicht über umwege und euer unser
steuersystem ist schon sehr kompliziert
nicht über umwege sondern einer direkten
entlastung sehr richtig und das werden
wir auch weiter fördern und unterstützen
nur die direkte entlassung ist es ja
wenn man weniger steuern zahlt dann geht
das direkte netto in die tasche der
menschen und so sollten was machen das
betrifft mich wiederhole das kleine und
mittlere einkommen frau lötzsch und
insofern diese debatten um
spitzenverdiener und sonst was ist aus
meiner sicht fehl am platz wir haben zum
ersten und zweiten installationspaket
gemacht die kleinen und mittleren
einkommen entlastet und wir werden im
herbst darüber diskutieren ob wir in der
breite entlasten und das steuersystem an
der stelle also sie wollen die
spitzenverdiener wieder entlasten haben
jetzt noch mal deutlich gesagt hatte er
habe ich gerade gesagt der große
unterschied zwischen uns das ist ja auch
gut dass es die unterschiede erkennbar
sind in der politik und jeder alle live
ein slogan wir ja wie definieren sie
leistungsträger zum beispiel eine
pflegekraft die aufstocken muss ist die
keine leistungsträgerinnen also
natürlich hätte sie das ich bin lasten
wir durch den erhöhten grundfreibetrag
ich verstehe gar nicht warum sie im
bundestag dagegen gestimmt haben also
genau die entlasten wir durch den
erhöhten nein wir sind wir
für die erhöhung der grundfreibeträge
das ist ja klar aber menschen die so ein
geringes einkommen haben dass sie quasi
nicht mal in diese steuer kategorie
fallen den nutzt das was kollegin julia
propagiert überhaupt nicht die brauchen
eine direkte unterstützung viel besser
wäre eigentlich dass sie ordentlich
bezahlt werden und sogar müsste der
bundestag natürlich auch mutige schritte
ergreifen um die mindestlöhne zu erhöhen
da ist die fdp
dann freut da ist die fdp ja das ist ein
kleiner schritt in die richtige richtung
aber nicht ausreichend wird auch alles
sofort wieder aufgefressen und da
brauchen wir größere schritte denn es
werden ja überall menschen gesucht die
arbeitgeber suchen fachkräfte und sie
müssen sie ihre zahlen das ist die
entscheidende frage und so können wir
noch mindestens ein viertel stunde
weitermachen nicht allzu hoch
interessanter hoch interessanter
austausch des wie ich finde und auch
sehr klar und auf den punkt ich habe
auch noch jede menge andere stichworte
hätte ich gehabt haben wir aber nicht
denn die zeit unsere zeit hier ist um um
10 beginnt die sitzung drin frau loth
vielen dank dass ihr heute morgen bei
uns gewesen findet auch innen hell wir
vielen herzlichen dank für diese
argumente und den austausch von
argumenten meine damen und herrn wir
schauen direkt in den plenarsaal und ich
versuche mal zu erkennen ob die
bundestagspräsident wird schon an ihrem
platz ist ist sie nicht macht nichts
sage ich ihm das in den nächsten stunden
hier passiert und zwar gucken wir dazu
auf die tagesordnung ist beginnt
natürlich wie immer mit dem punkt
finanzen also mit dem einzelplan
beziehungsweise beginnt eigentlich mit
dem einzelplan für den bundespräsidenten
im bundestag und dem bundesrat wird aber
ohne debatte hier verabschiedung dann
geht es weiter mit der allgemeinen
finanzdebatte und natürlich auch mit dem
etat des bundesfinanzministeriums jetzt
haben sie vielleicht im hintergrund den
gang gehört und jetzt sehen sie genauso
gut wie ich die bundestagspräsident fiel
auf dem weg zu ihrem platz und das heißt
wir gehen rein ins plenum die
haushaltswoche ist in wenigen sekunden
dann eröffnet
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich wünsche einen schönen
guten morgen die sitzung ist eröffnet
interfraktionell wurde vereinbart die
tagesordnung um die in der zusatzpunkte
liste aufgeführten ergänzungen zu
erweitern ich mache zudem auf eine
nachträgliche ausschuss überweisung im
anhang der zusatz punkteliste aufmerksam
sehr sie sind damit einverstanden
dann ist das so beschlossen außerdem
soll die stellungnahme des bundesrates
und die gegenäußerung der
bundesregierung auf drucksache
1974 zu dem gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung zur rentenanpassung
2022 an den federführenden ausschuss für
arbeit und soziales sowie an den mit
beratenden haushaltsausschuss überwiesen
werden auch hierzu sehe ich keinen
widerspruch dann ist die drucksache
überwiesen
jetzt bitte ich kurz noch mal um
aufmerksamkeit bevor ich nämlich die
tagesordnung aufrufe möchte ich ein ein
sportliches großereignis erinnern
am vergangenen wochenende sind wir
nämlich fußball europameister geworden
falls die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
kurz irritiert sind wir haben
tatsächlich ein fc bundestag
und ich möchte dem mannschaftskapitän
machen und es mir ganz herzlich im namen
von uns allen zum sieg gratulieren
herzlichen glückwunsch und wir freuen
uns alle mit dass wir nach fast elf
jahren
erstmalig ein turnier gewonnen
möglicherweise bin ich nicht ganz
unbeteiligt ich habe zwar nicht
mitgespielt aber ich habe damit gedroht
wenn es kein sieg gibt werde ich keine
dienstreise mehr genehmigen
damit rufe ich jetzt aber die
tagesordnung auf
und zwar die tagesordnungspunkte römisch
1 buchstabe a und b die zweite beratung
der von der bundesregierung
eingebrachten entwürfe eines gesetzes
über die feststellung des bundes
haushaltsplans für das haushaltsjahr
2022 und eines gesetzes zur ergänzung
des gesetzentwurfs über die
feststellungen des bundes haushaltsplans
für das haushaltsjahr
2022 sowie die beratung der
beschlussempfehlung des
haushaltsausschusses zum finanzplan des
bundes 2021 bis 2025
wir kommen zur beratung der einzelpläne
und zwar zunächst der drei einzelpläne
zu denen keine aussprache vorgesehen ist
die rufe ich den einzelplan 0 1 auf für
den bundespräsidenten und das
bundespräsidialamt mit den
beschlussempfehlungen des
haushaltsausschusses auf den drucksachen
1627 die berichterstattung haben die
abgeordneten dr dietmar bartsch dennis
rohde kerstin radomski sven christian
kindler otto fricke und peter böhringer
wir kommen nun zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 0 1 in der ausschuss fassung
wer stimmt dafür
das sieht nach allen fraktionen aus
verstimmt dagegen niemand enthaltungen
damit ist der einzelplan 0 1 so
angenommen und hier einzelplan 01 da
geht es um dem etat für den
bundespräsidenten für den bundestag und
den bundesrat traditionell ohne
aussprache diskutiert und wir gehen
einen schritt weiter kommen zum
einzelplan
08 wie die
bundestagspräsidentin eben schon
referiert hat dass es geht um der täter
in den ddr des bundesfinanzministeriums
und auch der etat für den
bundesrechnungshof wird in diesem
zusammenhang mit diskutiert und dann
anschließend auch in erster lesung
abgestimmt wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltung damit ist der einzelplan nur
zwei einstimmig angenommen
ich rufe auf den einzelplan 0 3 für den
bundesrat mit der beschlussempfehlung
des haushaltsausschusses auf drucksache
1627 berichterstattung haben die
abgeordneten dr michael espendiller
esther dilcher franziska hoppermann dr
sebastian schäfer torsten herbst und
victor perli wir stimmen ab über den
einzelplan 03 wer stimmt dafür
gegenstimmen
enthaltungen dann ist der einzelplan 03
einstimmig angenommen jetzt rufe ich auf
die einzelpläne 0
bundesministerium der finanzen ist der
einzelplan 08 mit der
beschlussempfehlung des
haushaltsausschusses auf den drucksachen
1608 und
1626 berichterstattung haben die
abgeordneten dr thorsten rudolph doktor
ingeborg gräßle sven christian kindler
christoph meyer wolfgang wille und dr
gesine lötzsch und für den
bundesrechnungshof das ist der
einzelplan 20 mit der
beschlussempfehlung des
haushaltsausschusses auf der drucksache
berichterstattung haben die abgeordneten
dr ingeborg gräßle dr thorsten rudolph
felix banaszak frank schäffler ulrike
schilke ziesing und dr gesine lötzsch
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
90 minuten vor allem
ich eröffne die aussprache und das wort
hat als erstes dr mathias middelberg für
die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
wir erleben eine denkwürdige
haushaltswoche wieder mit einem
bundeshaushalt in rekord größenordnung
von
annähernd 500 milliarden in einer ebenso
denkwürdigen zeit
in einer zeitenwende zeit wie der
bundeskanzler das zu recht betont hat
corona pandemie klimawandel
rekord-inflation die höchste seit 40
jahren und ukraine krieg von der
zeitenwende
denkt man müsste man in ihrem haushalt
auch sehr deutlich etwas merken man
merkt aber nur etwas auf der
einnahmeseite oder sagen wir besser bei
den fehlenden einnahmen dass sie nämlich
mit den schulden in rekordhöhe nach oben
wandern
konsequent müssten sie eigentlich auf
der ausgabenseite arbeiten als
verantwortliche haushälter und als
verantwortliche finanzminister lindner
selbst vor dem ukraine krieg und selbst
noch nicht mal in ansehung der vollen
inflations größenordnung an sie haben
sie in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart alle aufgaben auf den
prüfstand zu stellen und sie haben auch
vereinbart im rahmen des haushalts
aufstellungsverfahren es auch
ausgabenkürzungen vorzunehmen eine
wichtige vorgabe wie wir finden
nennenswerte priorisierung oder
kürzungen sind allerdings in ihrem
haushalt nicht erkennbar
im gegenteil
die satteln einfach nur drauf
netto 6000 zusätzliche stellen im
personalbereich darüber könnte man an
der einen oder anderen stelle noch
diskutieren aber sie lassen sich es auch
selbst gut gehen sie diskutieren wir
alle diskutieren darüber ob das
parlament verkleinern sie machen es sich
selber in der regierung richtig fett mit
der rekordzahl von 37 parlamentarischen
staatssekretären in dieser größenordnung
hat es bisher noch keine bundesregierung
geschafft
und ihre fortschritts koalition setzt
auch in anderen feldern maßstäbe sie
sind gestartet
mit zusätzlich und reichlich
zusätzlichen beamten in den ministerien
in der spitze der ministerien in den
teuersten besoldungsstufen vor vier
jahren haben sie der alten großen
koalition vorgeworfen als 4 200 stellen
aufgebaut haben wer so anfängt sagte der
kollege fricke der haushaltssprecher der
fdp wer so anfängt macht am ende aus
einer schwarzen null ein schwarzes loch
der satz war ja gar nicht so falsch aber
er trifft auch sie noch viel härter zu
sie bauen jetzt 324 neue stellen top
stellen in den ministerien auf das ist
mal ganz deutlich mehr als alle
vorgängerregierungen
von zeitenwende reden sie aber sie
wenden nichts nicht in ihrem haushalt
den kernhaushalt da ist der verschuldung
240 milliarden dann haben wir gemeinsam
dafür sage ich an dieser stelle auch
herzlichen dank dass flächig gerne ein
das sondervermögen bundeswehr 100
milliarden neue schulden und dann haben
sie noch die 60 milliarden diebesgut aus
der letzten wahlperiode die sie
tatsächlich als diebesgut diese
kreditermächtigung nehmen sie mit rüber
und wenn man das dann aufaddiert gelangt
man zu 300 milliarden neuen schulden ja
die 60 milliarden müssen wir ehrlich bei
ihnen rein rechnen das sind 300
milliarden schulden und das ist der
absolute rekord bisher
so dann haben sie viele projekte die das
bürgergeld die kindergrundsicherung und
das klima geld dass herr heilen wir
jetzt ins gespräch bringt ist alles im
haushalt noch nicht abgebildet da sind
wir mal sehr gespannt aber das
wichtigste ist eigentlich und das größte
und bemerkenswertes zu versorgen ist
sie haben für den ganzen bereich der
sozialversicherung keine wirkliche
vorsorge getroffen und das wird in den
nächsten jahren und jahrzehnten das
drücken sste problem werden wir haben in
diesem land
vollbeschäftigung und wir haben auch
rekordbeschäftigung mit 45 millionen
beschäftigten die in die sozialkassen
einzahlen trotzdem sind wir nicht in der
lage daraus die rente zu finanzieren wir
können die krankenkasse nicht
finanzieren wir können die pflege auch
nicht finanzieren so und ich sag das
durchaus sie brauchen gar nicht so
brüllen dürfen ich sag das durchaus
selbstkritisch auch wir haben
die großen koalition dieses problem
geschoben der unterschied ist nur
folgender ihr bundeskanzler der heute
nicht hier ist hat mit diesem thema
wahlkampf gemacht er hat respekt
gefordert oder respekt angeboten
gegenüber den wähler und er hat gesagt
ich bin der kanzler ich bin der kanzler
klebten ihre plakate in der ganzen
republik stolz drauf ich bin der kanzler
für sichere renten sie haben für gar
nichts vorgesorgt im bereich sicherheit
der renten sie haben nur gesagt das
rentenniveau bleibt das gleiche an den
beiträgen ändern wir nichts und das
rentenalter ändern wir auch nicht wie
wollen sie das problem dann lösen das
problem können sie nur lösen indem sie
immer mehr steuergelder in die rente
schaufeln sie haben überhaupt keine
vorsorge getroffen um dieses kernthema
irgendwie zu bewältigen
das ist die
unverantwortlichen verantwortlichkeit
par excellence in der haushaltspolitik
und dass wir uns einordnen und wir
werden sie in zukunft daran regelmäßig
erinnern und daran auch messen wenn
dieser kanzler respekt gegenüber seinen
wählern hat dann müsste er sich ganz
zügig und zwar grundlegend dieses teams
themas reformierung der
sozialversicherungen annehmen
letzter punkt
entlastungspaket dafür wollen sie sich
wahrscheinlich auch feiern lassen
möglicherweise auch heute die
entlassungs pakete gehen aber bei ihnen
nicht nach dem motto das sie da
entlasten wo es wirklich zielgenau
erforderlich wäre da wo die belastungen
am größten sind sondern sie belastet sie
entlasten so dass jeder von ihren
ampelfarben jede ampel partei krieg so
ein bisschen was der eine die ist der
andere das und am ende sind sie dann
fröhlich und nach der zielgerichteten
entlastung der bürger wird nicht gefragt
und die findet auch nicht statt dies ist
sogar im kern ungerecht und deswegen
fordern wir dass auch pendler adäquat in
diesen paketen berücksichtigung finden
und genau so auch händler und studenten
die haben die gleichen leistung und die
haben genauso entlastung von ihnen zu
erwarten
und wir
sie geben hier diese entlastung oder
sprechen darüber immer mit seiner
gönnerhaften attitüde jetzt gehen wir
den bürgern dies und das und ja und
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen mehr
dann wird über dies und jenes diskutiert
sie haben massiv mehreinnahmen im moment
aus der jetzigen situation und der
finanzminister hat hier noch vor ein
paar wochen erklärt das ging alles nicht
die leute wenn sie das geld dann da
nicht hätten würden sie es gar nicht
ausgeben wir sehen doch jetzt an den
steuerschätzung sehr deutlich dass
laufend steigende steuereinnahmen auf
sie zu fließen laufen steigende
steuereinnahmen
sie haben zusätzliche einnahmen aus der
umsatzsteuer im zweijahresvergleich in
der steigerung um 30 prozent gegenüber
der vorperiode zeit sie haben
zusätzliche einer
wir haben und ich sage ihnen ganz
ehrlich ihr erwartet von ihnen nicht
dass die denner haft irgendetwas
zurückgeben aber wir erwarten von ihnen
dass sie den menschen das zurückgeben
was ihnen vorher höhere steuern und
abgaben aus der tasche gezogen haben das
muss sein besten dank
mathias middelberg der stellvertretende
vorsitzende der unions fraktion hatte
die debatte eröffnet wir sind in der
allgemeinen finanzdebatte wir sind aber
auch beim etat des bundesfinanzministers
und diebesgut hat er gesagt zu einer
verschiebung einer kreditermächtigung
die mal geplant war um corona erfolgen
auszugleichen und die jetzt für projekte
des klimafonds genutzt werden soll da
gibt es auch eine entsprechende klage in
karlsruhe
nächster redner christoph meyer für die
fdp-fraktion
letzten krisen haushalt wir
dokumentieren die notlage am freitag in
time nochmaligen beschluss nach artikel
wir haben viel über krisen gesprochen
über die zeitenwende diskutiert und eine
folge das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr beschließen wir ebenfalls im
nächsten tagen und ich möchte hier ganz
klar stellen dieses sondervermögen ist
ein volk dieser chor ist ein erfolg
dieser koalition von bundeskanzler
scholz von christian linder als
verhandlungsführer aber auch von
annalena baerbock und ich danke explizit
der union dass sie hier ihrer
staatspolitischen verantwortung gerecht
geworden ist und mit uns zusammen einen
sehr guten kompromiss gefunden hat
herr mittelberg wir haben zwei
entlastungs paket geschnürt mit über 40
milliarden euro entlastungsvolumen in
den nächsten jahren und nun sagen sie
und das zieht sich wie ein roter faden
durch die beiträge der union in den
haushaltsberatungen dass es von allem
immer etwas mehr sein muss ich habe von
ihnen den haushaltsberatungen keinen
einzigen seriösen gegen
finanzierungsvorschlag gehört sie
fordern einfach nur immer mehr das ist
eine rolle als oppositionsfraktion die
wird dann irgendwann auf die füße fallen
und zur wahrheit gehört auch dazu dass
wir in den parlamentarischen beratungen
6 milliarden euro mehr für zinskosten
einstellen mussten das heißt die stadt
die zeit der staatsverschuldung ohne
aufwand ist vorbei und umso wichtiger
wird es dass wir im jahr 2023 zur
haushaltspolitischen normalität
zurückkehren dreh und angelpunkt dass es
gut das können sie tun dreh und
angelpunkt ist die einhaltung der
schuldenbremse 20 23 und 20 24 25 das
werden wir in den folgejahren
sicherstellen und wenn die fdp die es in
den letzten tagen immer wieder betont
dies ist keine frage einer partei
position es ist zwingende vorgabe der
verfassung welche diese gesamte
koalition und diese ganze regierung
einzuhalten hat und daher wird auch die
gesamte koalition insgesamt aufgefordert
sein bei den ausgaben zu priorisieren
und zu konsolidieren
und wenn das statistische bundesamt
gestern eine inflationsrate von 7,9
prozent gemeldet hat wo der bund nur
bedingt gegensteuern kann auch das
gehört dazu zu sagen werden wir die
vorhandenen spielräume im herbst für
dringende entlastungen bei den
bürgerinnen und bürger nutzen müssen und
da begrüßen wir dass der arbeitsminister
am wochenende einen debattenbeitrag
geleistet hat aber für uns ist noch klar
dass zunächst der abbau der kalten
progression und vordergrund stehen muss
ist eine frage der gerechtigkeit dass
der staat nicht auch noch an
preissteigerungen sich bereichern darf
und profitieren darf
meine damen und herren ich möchte den
dank für sehr konstruktive
haushaltsberatungen in den ampel
fraktionen aussprechen wir werden im
juni ende juni bereits den haushalt für
das jahr 2023 im bundeskabinett haben da
geht es weiter der bundesfinanzminister
hat zu beginn dieses jahres gesagt jetzt
22 der haushalt ist primär noch eine
weiterschreiben der großen koalition
auch wenn wir viele veränderungen
vornehmen mussten an im jahr 2023 an dem
haushalt können wir den finanzminister
zu den messen lassen können wir diese
koalition messen lassen ich freue mich
auf die beratung und danken für die
aufmerksamkeit
so viel beratung gibt es nicht mehr
denn es wird ja am ende dieser woche
abgestimmt über den bundeshaushalt 20 22
wir haben also noch ein wenig debatte
dazu und die beratung haben
stattgefunden ebenso die
bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltsausschusses
peter böhringer ist am pult
haushaltspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion
euro bei 1 139 milliarden
neuverschuldung das sechsfache dessen
was das grundgesetz normalerweise
erlaubt erneut wird eine haushalterische
notsituation geltend gemacht obwohl 2022
keinerlei pandemische notsituation
vorliegt in den haushaltsberatungen
wurde nicht einmal klar gestellt ob man
zur begründung der notsituation auch
immer nur corona als jahrhundert
ausnahme heran oder ob nun auch der
ukraine konflikte begründung sein soll
der entsprechend klären der antrag wurde
die bundestag erst gestern abend um 21
uhr vorgelegt das ist ein unmögliches
vorgehen zumal sie selbst darin nun
nicht eindeutig klarstellen mit welcher
notstands begründung sie eigentlich
gerade an der schuldenbremse
vorbeiregieren
und dieses intransparente schauspiel
wiederholt sich ja gerade auch noch beim
geplanten bundeswehr sondervermögen auch
dort war noch bis gestern abend unklar
auf welcher artikel grundlage des
grundgesetzes und mit welcher genauen
zweckbestimmung es eigentlich an diesem
freitag errichtet werden soll solch ein
gesetzgeberischer schweinsgalopp in
zentralen politik fragen mit steuer
auswirkungen im dreistelligen
milliardenbereich ist eine groteske
missachtung des parlaments
jedenfalls hätte man auch 2022 die
schuldenbremse einhalten können wenn man
die richtigen prioritäten gesetzt hätte
die von uns aufgezeigten
einsparpotenziale liegen bei mehr als
160 milliarden euro der etf bzw der
klima und transformations- hohe kann als
reine ideologie titel weitgehend
gestrichen werden
auch die sogenannte asyl klage ist
endlich aufzulösen im einzelplan des
gesundheitsministers muss die
vervierfachung des etats die
vervierfachung gegenüber
2009/10 endlich beendet werden über 40
milliarden euro corona ausgaben sind
ohne jeden nachteil für die bürger zu
streichungen zu streichen die zahlen an
die krankenhäuser für leerstehende
betten die kosten für tests für
impfstoffe für das offenhalten der
impfzentren im sommer das ist alles
überflüssig
natürlich auch die kosten für im
propaganda die öffentlichkeitsarbeit des
gesundheitsministeriums wurde mit corona
von 5 auf 210 millionen euro für 40 8
ampel und union wollen diese position
sogar nochmals verdoppeln das steht in
ihren anträgen die afg hatte all das
schon vor über zwei jahren gestrichen
bis auf unternehmenshilfen bis auch
diese die wir als ja nationale hilfen
notgedrungen mit tragen obwohl wir als
einzige partei immer gegen die korona
maßnahmen hysterie waren immer seit mai
20 20
minister lauterbach kauft impfstoffe für
alle denkbaren kollabieren eben erst
wieder für 830 millionen euro während
gleichzeitig dosen im milliardenwert
verfallen weiterhin geben wir milliarden
in den internationalen gesundheits
aufbau vor allem für weltweites impfen
aber auch freiwillige zahlungen an die
bh oben zudem möchte mir ernsthaft ein
prognosemodell für impfstoff bedarf die
ampel vertritt also noch immer den
absurden glauben künftige viren
pandemien voraussehen
genau die impfstoffe und der bedarf
gegen potenziell tausende von varianten
voraus planen und dafür ein modell
erstellen zu können so etwas ist einfach
nur abwegig
dann gender und klimaprogramm in aller
welt das sind die berüchtigten welt
beglückung programme der so genannten
agenda 2030 für eine demokratisch
niemals mehrheitsfähige transformationen
der welt
viel geld könnte man natürlich auch bei
der eu holen wenn man es denn wollte
deutschland erhält etwa nur ein viertel
dessen was uns aus dem riesigen eu
corona programm next generation zustände
und obwohl man das weiß wird in brüssel
ohne erkennbaren widerstand aus dem
finanzministerium schon der nächste
schulden topf konzipiert nur ein jahr
nach dem präzedenzfall der eu corona
hilfe es zeigt sich dass denn sie sagen
herr minister sie sagen es stimmt nicht
es angekündigt von frau von der leyen
und von ex anderen personen ist
angekündigt also dann bitte ich sie um
eine zwischenfrage wenn sie wirklich in
dieser form hier sagen es stimmt nicht
es zeigt sich dass der next generation
gemeinschaftsschulden topf kein
einzelfall war sondern ein dammbruch ich
sagte hier an dieser stelle schon 20 21
wenn dieser dann erst einmal gebrochen
ist dann wird brüssel immer wieder
riesige summen zu lasten deutscher
qualität aufnehmen und sie großzügig
umverteilen meine prognose ein neues eu
unterstütztes schulden programm über
hunderte milliarden euro wird kommen mit
sichtbarem deutschen anteil die es der
finanzminister ausdrückt alle deutschen
steuerzahler werden absehbar drei bis
sechs monate arbeiten alleine nur zur
absicherung dieses sichtbaren deutschen
anteils
wir retten die ganze welt mit von
deutschland behafteten schulden aber für
die eigenen leute gibt es viel zu wenig
geld zumindest kein geld
und vor diesem hintergrund lesen wird
ein solcher sätze des finanzministers
man kann abhängig werden von
staatsverschuldung wir müssen die sucht
nach verschuldung beenden zitat ende das
sagen sie herr lindner ernsthaft nachdem
sie selbst in nur sechs monaten im amt
nun volle 200 milliarden euro
aufgenommen haben zuzüglich bundeswehr
sondervermögen wir hörten ist ja eben
schaffe herrn mittelberg sind es dann
sogar 300 milliarden schulden kfd ist
der auffassung dass auch dieser haushalt
wieder erneut verfassungswidrig ist man
darf keine notkredite aufnahmen um
rücklagen zu bilden was sie aber auch 22
erneut getan haben das ist und bleibt
ein missbrauch des ausnahme artikels
diese schuldenpolitik der regierung wird
natürlich zu immer noch mehr inflation
führen auch mit dem 22er haushalt gießt
die koalition weiteres benzin ins feuer
und wo obwohl die afg natürlich die seit
jahrzehnten angelegten inflation zur
sachen auch nicht über nacht aus der
welt schaffen könnte konnten wir doch
gegen die inflations folgen
weitreichende steuerentlastungen
vorschlagen und auch gegenfinanzieren
das sind die erhöhung des
grundfreibetrags das kommt fast allen
zugute auf 12.600 euro die aussetzung
der umsatzsteuer auf lebensmittel und
treibstoffe die längst fällige fällige
und überfällige abschaffung des solis
die abschaffung der sinnfreien co2
besteuerung all das ist gegenfinanziert
die regierung profitiert über hohe
steuereinnahmen absurderweise von der
schulden inflation die sie selbst
befeuert für die menschen dagegen ist
die inflation der große für arme kleine
leute mit nur langsam wachsenden
einkünften stehen plötzlich viel ärmer
da eine regierung die das verursacht ist
zutiefst antisozialen
doch etwa die größten grünen begrüßen
sogar die inflation der hohe preis der
klima ideologie ist nun da die grünen
finden das auch noch gut lebensmittel
seien eigentlich viel zu billig und
deutschland sei für die ukraine bereit
einen hohen wirtschaftlichen preis zu
zahlen zudem beklagt frau berbalk auch
noch die kriegsmüdigkeit der menschen
werden nicht nur von abgehobene
ideologen sondern auch von zynikern
regiert
peter pühringer aus der fdp-fraktion wo
ihr haushaltspolitischer sprecher ist
und haushaltspolitischer sprecher ist
auch der nächste redner der nässe oder
aus der spd fraktion möchte ich noch mal
einen kurzen hinweis an die mitglieder
der regierungsbank geben
zwischenrufe zwischen bemerkungen die
ich laut höre aber auch andere sind
nicht gestattet
und jetzt rufe ich den nächsten redner
auf für die spd-fraktion dennis rohde
[Applaus]
geschätzte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir
beraten in dieser woche abschließen den
bundeshaushalt 20 22 und ja wir sehen
noch mal eine hohe kreditaufnahme von
139 milliarden euro vor das sind und das
gehört dann aber auch zur wahrheit 100
milliarden euro weniger als das was 20
21 in der großen koalition geplant war
und das hat verschiedene gründe
der erste grund ist dass wir viele
maßnahmen nicht mehr brauchen nicht mehr
finanzieren müssen weil sich viele
menschen in diesem land solidarisch
gezeigt haben sich impfen lassen haben
und den gilt allen unser dank liebe
kollegen
an der zweite grund ist
dass wir verbesserte steuereinnahmen
haben dass wir eine wirtschaft haben die
sich gerade als stabil herausstellt und
der grund liegt auch in den maßnahmen
die wir in der vergangenheit getroffen
haben dadurch dass wir arbeitsplätze
durch das kurzarbeitergeld gesichert
haben dadurch dass die unternehmen durch
wirtschaften gesichert haben stehen wir
heute so da wie wir dastehen wesentlich
besser als das was im letzten jahr
status quo war und das ist finde ich
auch ein erfolg der politik der letzten
jahre liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aber dieser haushalt ist mit
unsicherheiten behaftet der ukraine
konflikt mit seinen verschiedensten
auswirkungen auf der ausgabeseite aber
auch auf der einnahmeseite wir wissen
nicht wie sich das wirtschaftswachstum
in der zweiten jahreshälfte entwickelt
wir wissen nicht welche auswirkungen die
inflation auf der ausgabeseite auch für
den bundeshaushalt hat wir haben eine
situation wo die zinsen steigern und wir
eigentlich mal eingeplante negativ
zinseinnahmen jetzt nicht mehr haben
also alles das was wir als
planungsgrundlage haben ist durchaus
volatil und trotzdem und gerade dessen
müssen wir uns den herausforderungen die
da auf uns zukommt stellen und ich will
das am beispiel der ukraine machen
während der bereinigungssitzung haben
die g7-finanzminister getagt während der
bereinigungssitzung hat man beschlossen
15 milliarden euro liquiditätshilfen der
ukraine kurzfristig zur verfügung zu
stellen und uns war wichtig diesen
deutschen anteil eine milliarde euro
noch in der nacht in den bundeshaushalt
zu überführen um deutlich zu machen an
dieser frage stehen legislative und
exekutive geschlossen ein zeichen der
solidarität das auch aus der
bereinigungssitzung ausgegliedert
gelegen
139 milliarden euro und zur wahrheit
gehört am ende kommen noch 100
milliarden euro dazu nämlich das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr um die
truppe endlich wieder vernünftig auf
vordermann zu bringen und die
bundesrepublik wehrhaft zu machen ich
danke all denen die sich ihrer
staatspolitischen verantwortung an
dieser stelle stellen die dafür sorge
tragen dass dieses sondervermögen
realität wird wir brauchen ist und wir
bringen es auf den weg und sind damit
auch vorbild für viele andere nationen
um uns herum liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
mein dank gilt besonders gegen
diejenigen die verhandelt haben mein
besonderer dank geht dem bundeskanzler
der die initiative angestoßen hat er
diese sondervermögen auf den weg
gebracht hat aber auch dem
finanzminister der
verteidigungsministerin der
außenministerin und den vertreterinnen
und vertreter der union die an der sache
orientiert zu einem guten ergebnis
gekommen sind in allen im namen der
spd-fraktion vielen dank
die äußere sicherheit ist prägend für
diesen bundeshaushalt weil wir da die
großen herausforderungen haben bei der
bundeswehr bei der unterstützung der
ukraine aber wir haben in der debatte
auch die anderen sicherheiten nicht
vergessen die innere sicherheit und die
soziale sicherheit wir stärken die
innere sicherheit ganz gezielt zum
beispiel durch 2000 zusätzliche
bundespolizisten und bundespolizisten
die ab 20 25 20 26 unsere bahnhöfe und
flughäfen sicherer machen werden und
dann kann man in ställen auf uns der
ampel kritisieren aber am ende sagen wir
damit für zusätzliche sicherheit und ich
finde das sollte auch im interesse der
union seine kollegen und probieren
und wir lernen aus der katastrophe im
aartal wir haben gemerkt welches
material den technischen hilfswerks
fehlte und haben mit diesen
bundeshaushalt zum beispiel dafür
gesorgt dass dem technischen hilfswerk
zusätzliche unimog zur verfügung
gestellt werden dass die zusätzliche
logistikzentren bekommen damit sie alles
das was sie im krisenfall brauchen auch
vorhalten können auch das ist ein
beitrag für die innere sicherheit und
für den inneren zusammenhalt in diesem
land wieder kollegen kunden und
wir stärken die soziale sicherheit durch
entlastungspaket mit einmal zuschüssen
durch die möglichkeit kostengünstig den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr zu
nutzen was gerade in den nächsten wochen
und monaten vielen menschen auch
ermöglicht in den ferienzeiten zu reisen
die es sich durch die inflation
ansonsten nicht mehr leisten könnten
auch ein beitrag zum zusammenhalt durch
die senkung der energie steuer auf
kraftstoffe all das sind maßnahmen die
ein ziel haben in zeiten von krieg um
uns herum von inflation dieses land
zusammenzuhalten und diese aufgabe gehen
wir an in der ampel liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
aber auch beim thema soziales spielt die
ukraine wieder mit rein wir stärken ganz
gezielt in etat des
bundesarbeitsministers zum beispiel
durch die möglichkeit 200 millionen euro
zusätzlich für eingliederungsmaßnahmen
zu nutzen zum beispiel für über 100
millionen euro zusätzliche deutschkurse
damit diejenigen die beim schutz suchen
auch eine perspektive in diesem land
haben und auch das ist ein beitrag zur
sozialen sicherheit dieses landes liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir vergessen dabei nicht dass wir
nicht nur eine verantwortung für unser
land tragen ja die krisen um uns herum
sie treffen die europäische union und
sie treffen die bundesrepublik
deutschland hat aber es gibt regionen
die werben um so härter getroffen weil
es da dann teilweise und die blanke
existenz um das blanke überleben geht
uns war es wichtig deutlich zu machen
dass wir unsere internationalen
verpflichtungen
dass wir die krisen die zum beispiel auf
dem afrikanischen kontinent entstehen
mit blick auf große ernährungsprobleme
dass wir die seen und angehen und
deshalb wird mit diesem bundeshaushalt
der bereich der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit noch mal um
2,4 milliarden euro im vergleich zum
regierungsentwurf gestärkt das ist ein
starkes signal der internationalen
solidarität dieses bundeshaushalt
und wir vergessen auch nicht diejenigen
die es in der krise besonders schwer
hatten die kulturschaffenden zum
beispiel den ihre gesamte existenz für
viele monate geraubt worden wir stärken
wieder erneut die kultur in großem
umfang nicht nur bei den investitionen
wo wir kommunen und länder unterstützen
wollen dass sie das was sie an
kulturgütern halten auch erhalten können
sondern zb auch in dem wir in diesem
jahr einen zusätzlichen zuschuss an die
künstlersozialkasse geben wollen damit
im nächsten jahr der beitragssatz
stabilisiert werden kann und die
künstler die es in den letzten jahren eh
schon besonders werten nicht dort noch
doppelt hart getroffen werden liebe
kollegen
abschließend ja dieser haushalt ist mit
vielen unsicherheiten behaftet
aber er ist ausdruck unserer
gesamtverantwortung
für die äußere für die innere und für
die soziale sicherheit es ist ein
haushalt des zusammenhalts und unsere
fraktion wird dem gern zustimmen
dennis rohde der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion betonte
nochmal äußere innere und soziale
sicherheit seien bedacht worden beim
haushalt 20 22 zumindest in einem fall
wird widerspruch zu erwarten seien von
janine wissler der vorsitzenden der
linken meine damen und herren ja dieser
haushaltswoche zeit ja ganz gut die
prioritätensetzung dieser ampel
regierung in wenigen wochen haben sie
sich mit der union darauf geeinigt auf
100 milliarden sondervermögen genauer
gesagt sondern schulden für die
bundeswehr und dazu soll jetzt das
grundgesetz geändert werden das heißt
aufrüstung soll in diesem land
verfassungsrang bekommen ich will nur
darauf hinweisen dass der
verteidigungshaushalt schon seit 2014 um
insgesamt 40 prozent erhöht wurden und
die linke wird dieses sondervermögen
dieses 100 milliarden paket und auch das
2 prozent abgerüstet aufrüstung stil wir
lehnen das ab wir werden dagegen stimmen
weil aufrüstung macht diese welt nicht
gütig und
was könnte man mit diesen 100 milliarden
alles sinnvolles tun man könnte zum
beispiel alle schulen in der
bundesrepublik sanieren und sie wissen
auch dass es viele dringend nötig haben
investitionen
klimaschutz in die verkehrswende dafür
bräuchten wir doch dreistellige
milliarden programme und was tun sie
denn meine damen und herren gegen die
wachsende soziale ungleichheit in diesem
land die versprochen der
kindergrundsicherung findet sich nicht
im haushalt ist verschoben auf 20 24 das
heißt sie haben den kampf gegen
kinderarmut um zwei jahre verschoben ich
frage sie was gibt es denn dringend da
riss als kinder und familien aus der
armut holen meine damen und herren
in einer zeit in der viele familien
überhaupt nicht mehr wissen wie sie ihre
wochen einkäufe noch bezahlen sollen wo
viele nicht wissen wie sie die
gasrechnungen bezahlen wollen oder die
immer weiter steigenden mieten da ist es
doch so dringend notwendig die kleinen
und mittleren einkommen diese menschen
zu entlasten wo sind denn die milliarden
für die fliege das wurde den
pflegekräften in der korona krise
versprochen dass es verbesserungen für
ihre arbeitsbedingungen geben soll wo
sind da die milliarden die eingestellt
sind und wir sagen ganz klar auch in
dieser krise werden eben nicht allen
aber es gibt einige die sehr gut
verdienen an dieser krise das sind die
krisengewinnler deswegen ist es dringend
notwendig diese exorbitanten gewinne
endlich vernünftig zu besteuern hohe
einkommen vermögen zur finanzierung
öffentlicher aufgaben heranzuziehen aber
das thema umverteilung ist bei diesem
finanzminister und dieser
bundesregierung leider eine lehrstelle
nächster gegner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen sven christian kindler
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren zehn wochen
parlamentarische arbeit an diesem
bundeshaushalt liegen hinter uns das ist
der erste haushalt der ampelkoalition
das waren sehr besonderer raus vorne
eine beratung die wir hatten bei dieser
hause den zeiten großer globaler krisen
aufgestellt wurde um mit diesem haushalt
geben wir konkrete antworten auf diese
krisen wir geben konkrete antworten auf
den schrecklichen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine wir geben antworten auf die
krise des klimas und des artensterbens
wir geben auch antworten auf die immer
noch anhaltende corona pandemie und
gegeben auch antworten auf die vor allem
fossil betriebene inflation wir geben
konkrete antworten im haushalt auf die
krisen aber wir haben auch konkret für
die zukunft lernen aktiv mit diesem
bundeshaushalt in dieser krise
und wir betreiben aber nicht nur aktive
krisenbewältigung sondern wir sorgen
auch für die zukunft vor wir haben die
investitionen im parlamentarischen
verfahren bereinigungssitzung noch mal
um 7 oder millionen euro erhöht und
insgesamt wenn man den energie und
klimafonds zusammennimmt den
kernhaushalt um das sondervermögen
digitalen infrastruktur mit rekordwert
von investitionen von 75 milliarden euro
in diesem haushalt
wir konnten seit beginn der
ampelkoalition
das volumen des energie und klimafonds
für die nächsten jahre auf fast 200
milliarden euro verdoppeln und wir haben
ein parlamentarischer kann noch mal den
nationalen klimaschutz gestärkt wir
haben internetzugang klima und wir die
biodiversitätsschutz gestärkt die
unterstützen urbane räume bei der
anpassung an die klimakrise wir haben
die digitalisierung der schiene mit 400
millionen euro in den nächsten jahren
gestärkt und worauf wir besonders stolz
sind wir haben auch endlich die
finanzierung für das polar
forschungsschiff polarstern zweifel das
forschungsschiff polarstern 2 endlich
gesichert das ein ganz wichtiger beitrag
die forschung aber auch für den
klimaschutz
das sondervermögen wurde schon
angesprochen es ist richtig dass werth
die bundeswehr in den nächsten jahren
angemessen ausstatten und dass wir im
haushaltsausschuss auch gleichzeitig
beschlossen haben dass wir eine
notwendige reform
beschaffungswesen eng begleiten werden
zusammen mit dem rechnungshof
und ich kann ehrlich gesagt ja
allerdings sich die union verstehen dass
im 21 jahrhundert cyber abwehr kein teil
des sondervermögens sein sollte ehrlich
das ist von vorgestern liebe union
aber ich will noch etwas ich will auch
etwas loben biste union sagen ich
begrüße ausdrücklich dass die union ihre
ideologische position war im
sondervermögen geräumt hatten eine
neuverschuldung von 100 milliarden euro
an der schuldenbremse vorbei zugestimmt
hat so wird jetzt die ausstellung der
bundeswehr nicht gegen notwendige
gerechtigkeit notwendig klimaschutz im
haushalt ausgespielt dafür danke ich
herzlich
dennis rola des angesprochenen
sicherheit bemisst sich aber nicht nur
an die militärausgaben sondern auch die
ausgaben für diplomatie zivile
krisenprävention und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sind zentral
für unsere sicherheitspolitik in der
einen welt wir sehen ja gerade wie
wladimir putin gezielt mit ernährung und
mit hunger einen krieg führt ein korn
trick weltweit und versucht die
internationale gemeinschaft auch zu
spalten und deswegen ist es gut dass wir
den zweiten regierungsentwurf noch mal
deutlich nachgebessert haben im
ergänzungs haushalt im parlamentarische
verfahren wir haben jetzt 2,7 milliarden
euro mehr fürs auswärtige amt und für
das bmz bereitstellen können weil ich
zentral diplomatie und zivile
krisenprävention der kampf gegen hunger
zentrale tann und sicherheitspolitik
sind aber wir erwarten auch als fraktion
dass die 11 regelungen die im
koalitionskrach festgehalten ist dass
die auch für die nächsten haushalte und
der finanzplanung deutlich abgesichert
wird weil es nicht nur in diesem
haushalt große krisen gibt sondern auch
in den nächsten jahren wird es weiterhin
große krisen auch weltweit geben und
deswegen brauchen wir eine absicherung
in der finanzplanung
und die linke und die union habe es
angesprochen und immer noch mehr geld
gefordert aber ich will darauf hinweisen
dass diese koalition innerhalb von
wenigen wochen zwei entlastungs paket in
höhe von über 40 milliarden euro
bereitgestellt hat unser fokus lag vor
allen dingen darauf menschen gezielt zu
entlassen und menschen auch sozial
gerecht zu entlassen das haben die
entlassungs paketen auch gezeigt
und natürlich gibt es auch noch
nachbesserungsbedarf
natürlich gibt es auch in der kürzer
zeit auch nachbesserungsbedarf das will
ich ehrlich zugeben nicht alle maßnahmen
auch 100 prozent ziel genau das sehen
wir gerade bei der befristete absenkung
der energie steuer aber wenn wir jetzt
strukturell daran gehen dass wir
entlastungen auch absichern wollen dann
haben wir da am koalitionsvertrag zwei
instrumente vereinbart die auch
strukturen dauerhaft zielgerecht und und
zielgenau wirken das ist das energie
geld finanziert aus allgemeinen
haushaltsmitteln und das ist die
kindergrundsicherung und ich gehe auch
davon aus dass die absicherung
koalitionsvertrag daneben auch in der
finanzplanung abgesichert wird
und natürlich können wir auch über neue
wege der finanzierung reden dafür sind
begrünen immer gerne offen für uns ist
klar dass bei der steuerpolitik ist vor
allem eine gerechte lastenverteilung
geht und deswegen sagen wir auch sehr
klar gerade in einer krise die so
fundamentales müssen starke schultern
deutlich mehr tragen als schwache es
gibt besonders für die steuerpolitik
herr mittelberg hat den energie und
klimafonds angesprochen und die 60
milliarden euro die sie jetzt in
karlsruhe klagen dh 60 milliarden euro
die nicht für die notwendige
transformation der wirtschaft und
klimaschutz bereit in den nächsten
jahren das ist ihr gutes recht wer hat
das innerlich für falsch und
verfassungsrechtlich für nicht tragfähig
was sie gemacht haben aber man kann
nicht gleichzeitig den egf und die 60
milliarden rücklagen k zu beklagen und
mittelberg und dann in der
bereinigungssitzung land antrag vorlegen
der diese 60 milliarden euro aktiviert
obwohl sie nach ihrer klage ein
verfallen sollten und als
gegenfinanzierung für anträge nutzen sie
müssen sich schon entscheiden was sie
konkret wollen das ist
haushaltstechnisch und rechtlich nicht
möglich und ihre klage in karlsruhe
haben damit ad absurdum geführt
kollege meyer des angesprochenen kollege
roger ist angesprochen wir müssen diesem
haushalt die notfall der schuldenbremse
ziehen weil wir immer noch die folgen
der korona pandemie sehen und weil wir
auch zusätzlich jetzt mit dem
schrecklichen krieg russlands gegen die
ukraine eine neue notlage haben die
große soziale ökonomische und humanitäre
herausforderung mit sich bringt und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir jetzt
hier konkret auf diese krisen reagieren
und aktiv handeln in der krise wir sagen
sehr klar mit diesem haus wir sparen uns
sind keine krisen hinein
und nicht wünsche mir und
ich wünsche mir sehr wirklich sehr dass
wir sehr schnell aus diesen krisen
wieder herauskommen so war das wirklich
schrecklich ist was wir gerade
tagtäglich sehen und viele menschen auch
weltweit besonders ukraine gerade
erleben müssen aber ich habe nicht die
hoffnung und ich habe die befürchtung
dass das nicht so schnell leider enden
wird wenn ich mir das handeln und die
schrecklichen pläne und wladimir putin
anschaue wenn ich mir die großen
internationalen folgen anschauen die
großen sozialen ökonomischen folgen es
wird deutschland europa hat anschaue
dann habe ich die große sorge dass das
nicht 2022 schon zu ende ist und dieser
konflikt ist kein 100 meter lauf sondern
das ist ein marathon und zentral ist
dass europa diesen zeiten fest und
geeint zusammensteht und sich nicht nur
wladimir putin auf der strecke dann
auseinander dividieren lässt
und
dies
ziel muss sich dann auch die
finanzpolitik mit ihrer dienen funktion
auch unterordnen deswegen ist es richtig
dass die europäische kommission jetzt zu
2023 die ausnahmeklausel stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt noch einmal beschlossen
hat europa hat aus den fehlern der
letzten finanzkrise um den fehlern der
austeritätspolitik gelernt in zeitnot
handelt man man spart sich in keine
krisen hinein
und deswegen bin ich auch noch mal klar
sagen deutschland hat als größte
volkswirtschaft europas eine besondere
verantwortung diesen zeiten und es geht
auch für die aufstellung des
bundeshaushalts
23 gerade wenn eine notlage besteht kann
man eben nicht den rotstift ansetzen an
normalität suggerierenden da muss man
aktiv handeln das notwendig auch
finanzieren
wir haben diesen raus erfahren 22
gezeigt wir sorgen aktiv für die zukunft
fort wir reagieren aktiv auf krisen wir
haben viel bewegt im haushaltsverfahren
wir haben die regierung dort unterstützt
wo es notwendig war wir haben sie auch
dort als selbstbewusst parlament
korrigiert und ergänzt wo es notwendig
war starke für die zusammenarbeit und
die zustimmung zu diesem haushalt danken
sven christian kindler weil das
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen hat
sich geäußert unter anderem auch zum
kompromiss der ampel mit der union beim
sonder etat für die bundeswehr wo der
bereich der cyber sicherheit ja erst mal
ausgeklammert worden ist der nächste
redner florian oßner aus der
unionsfraktion beziehungsweise aus der
csu-landesgruppe und nach ihm kommt der
bundesfinanzminister
das gleicht schon echt einem sehr teuren
wunschkonzert was hier die ampel
regierung als haushalt für das jahr 2022
vorgelegt hat alle vorlieben der
koalitionäre werden da gleichermaßen
bedient für die grünen ein bisschen
klima für die fdp ein bisschen politik
marketing und für die spd ein bisschen
soziales leider läuft dieses konzert
unter dem titel wer macht die meisten
schulden waren grüne und fdp in der
vergangenheit immer gegen
schattenhaushalte wollten subventionen
streichen und den solidaritätszuschlag
komplett abschaffen so bleiben darf und
nur noch leere worthülsen wirklich sehr
sehr schade die liebe ampelkoalition
ehre so schafft man definitiv kein
vertrauen in die finanzpolitik in
deutschland
es ist absehbar und die glaskugel das
auch bei uns die leitzinsen steigen wir
haben bereits eine rekord inflation und
damit wird auch das massive schulden
machen des bundes immer teurer also was
würde der vernünftige und vorsichtige
kaufmann machen richtig sich beschränken
prioritäten setzen ausgabenprogramme
überprüfen und gegebenenfalls auch dinge
streichen stattdessen bekommen wir einen
eine nettoneuverschuldung von rund
140 milliarden euro präsentiert dann
kommen noch durch buchungstricks weitere
60 milliarden euro corona kredite dazu
natürlich dass schulden finanziert die
sondervermögen bundeswehr in höhe von
100 milliarden euro sage und schreibe in
summe 300 milliarden euro neue schulden
und bei den parlamentarischen beratungen
wurden nochmals 11,9 milliarden euro
draufgesattelt damit bläht sich der
bundeshaushalt auf annähernd eine halbe
million euro auf das ist wirklich
wahnsinn und an verantwortungslosigkeit
in der tat nicht mehr zu überbieten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen danke
spare in der zeit dann hast du in der
not wir kennen alle diese alte weisheit
ohne das konsequente einhalten der
ausgeglichenen haushalte sei 2014 durch
unions geführte bundesregierungen hätten
wir die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
panini und jetzt des ukraine kriegs
nicht abfedern können die ampel scheint
hingegen bei jedem problem in den
finanzpolitischen amoklauf zu verfallen
hier ein paar milliarden da ein paar
milliarden ist wird nur noch in
milliarden einheiten gesprochen ohne
jeglicher
gegenfinanzierung beenden sie deshalb
bitte sofort diese sinnlose
verfrühstücken der zukunft unserer
nachfolgenden generationen
dass das wort zurückhaltung scheint
zudem für die ampel nicht im wortschatz
vorhanden zu sein das gilt insbesondere
dann wenn es um die vergabe von posten
geht insgesamt fast
10.000 zusätzliche stellen auch das
problem der ausgabereste in den
ministerien wird von der koalition
komplett ausgeblendet uni gehört knapp
20 milliarden euro haushalts transparenz
sieht wahrlich anders aus liebe
ampelkoalition ehre
als union fordern wir deshalb die
bundesregierung auch in unserem
entschließungsantrag auf senken sie die
neuverschuldung um über 100 milliarden
euro
durch die auflösung der rücklagen und
durch die nichtinanspruchnahme der
korona beziehungsweise klima kredite
entlasten sie die bürgerinnen und bürger
sowie die unternehmen durch die
beseitigung der kalten progression
im steuertarif und schaffen sie endlich
den solidaritätszuschlag komplett ab und
nehmen sie die personal währung zurück
welche sowieso am ende nur mehr
bürokratie schafft herzliches vergelt's
gott verstören
florian oßner aus der unionsfraktion
spricht von 300 milliarden neuen
schulden die die ampel koalition mache
das ist nur bedingt richtig der energie
100 milliarden für den für das
sondervermögen bundeswehr hat er mal mit
eingerechnet das sind aber bislang nur
kreditermächtigungen und wann die
wirksam werden wird sich weisen
christian lindner
vorgeschlagen dass sie die rücklagen
auflösen wollen die in ihrer eigenen
früheren mittelfristigen finanzplanung
noch benötigt worden ist um im nächsten
jahr die schuldenbremse des
grundgesetzes
einzuhalten das ist leider
widersprüchlich der wechsel von
regierungsrat musik man ist nicht
gekommen
ich bin ich aber auch bedanken für die
große einigkeit beim
sondervermögen von diesem sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr geht eine doppelte
botschaft aus wir stärken mit 100
milliarden euro investitionen unsere
fähigkeit zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
aber wir tun dies parallel zur
schuldenbremse des grundgesetzes
die schuldenbremse selbst bleibt für
alle anderen aufgaben und vorhaben
erhalten das ist die doppelte botschaft
wir antworten auf die
sicherheitspolitische zeitenwende mit
der stärkung der streitkräfte wir
antworten auf die ökonomische
zeitenwende der inflation durch die
rückkehr zu soliden haushalten und das
ende immer neuer schulden
damit folgen wir auch dem rat der
europäischen kommission wenn die
europäische kommission hat ja bei ihrem
finanzpolitischen ausblick zwar die
allgemeine auswahl klausel verlängert
zugleich hat sie aber nicht empfohlen
davon gebrauch zu machen im gegenteil
sie hat gesagt wir müssen zu
fiskalischer neutralität also nicht
durch immer neue subventionen und
ausgabenprogramme die inflationären und
genau das muss unser ziel sein rückkehr
zur schuldenbremse bedeutet druck von
den preisen nehmen indem wir nicht immer
mehr umverteilen und immer mehr
subventionen erfinden
herr kollege mittelberg im zweiten
regierungsentwurf
2022 haben wir genau ihre zahl von 99,7
milliarden euro nettokreditaufnahme
eingehalten wir haben nicht mehr
schulden gemacht als sie in ihrer
regierungszeit vor hatten aber wir haben
mit ihren eckpunkten anderes gemacht
mehr für bildung soziale aufgaben
investitionen und entlastung das zeigt
bereits mit dem zweiten
regierungsentwurf hat die ampel mit der
konsolidierung begonnen aber
neue aufgaben kamen hinzu
nur aufgaben kamen hinzu und deshalb
haben wir einen ergänzungs haushalt
bekanntlich vorgelegt weil dinge nicht
vorhersehbar war ich nenne als ein
beispiel tennis ohne darauf eingegangen
eine milliarde euro zuschuss um die
liquidität der ukraine zu erhalten damit
sie ihre starts funktionen garantieren
kann das zeigt die ampel koalition nimmt
internationale verantwortung wahr ohne
den ergänzungs haushalt und ohne die
klaren entscheidungen des
haushaltsausschusses wäre nicht
gesichert dass die ukraine ihr recht auf
selbstverteidigung verwirklichen kann
und je mehr einnahmen die der staat in
diesem jahr erzielt kollege mittelberg
gibt er zurück wir haben ein
entlastungspaket bzw mehrere entlastungs
paket mit in der summe über 30
milliarden euro geschnürt das was uns an
mehreinnahmen
zufließt das geht an die bürgerinnen und
bürger zurück auch dadurch indem ihr den
von der cdu csu für das jahr 2022
beschlossen steuertarif rückwirkend zum
ersten januar mit
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und höheren
grundfreibetrag korrigieren das war hier
erbe dieser steuertarif und
23 es kommen neue maßnahmen hinzu zum
beispiel eine befristete senkung der
energiesteuerung am morgigen tag gilt
die sie wird nicht sofort wirksam seien
aus technischen gründen es ist kein
geheimnis ich hätte ein anderes modell
vorgezogen ich hätte wie in italien ich
hätte die in italien eine beihilfe
empfohlen wo man direkte vorgaben an die
mineralölgesellschaften machen kann dass
er ein modell gewesen wir haben uns dann
im politischen diskurs entschieden für
eine steuersenkung diese steuersenkung
muss aber jetzt durchgesetzt werden das
ist jetzt eine aufgabe des kartellamts
wir müssen sicherstellen dass die
steuersenkung bei den autofahrerinnen
und war den pendlern ankommt denn für
die ist das gemeint nicht für die
mineralölgesellschaften
feuer auch ihr modell die steuern zu
senken sie wollten ja sogar noch die
mehrwertsteuer senken was aus
europäischen rechts gründen ohne
weiteres nicht möglich gewesen wäre und
letzter punkt zu den stellen wir reden
über den einzelplan nachts hat bisher
noch niemand getan deshalb will ich mama
weil sie auch kritik von der cdu csu kam
im einzelplan acht schaffe ich 1000 oder
schlage ich vor und der haushalts wird
ja von ihnen beschlossenen schlagen ich
vor 1400 zusätzliche stellen zu schaffen
für zöllnerinnen und zöllner
das ist eine investition
vom 2 der mittelwert wollen sie das
nicht will die cdu csu das nicht 1400
zöllnerinnen und zöllner ist eine
investition in die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
eines exportlandes damit das schnell
abgewickelt werden kann es ist zugleich
aber auch eine investition in die
bekämpfung von finanzkriminalität
geldwäsche und schwarzarbeit wollen sie
das nicht wir wurden
wir wollen das denn unser ziel ist es
die ehrlichen steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler vor mehrbelastungen zu
schützen indem wir die schwarzen schafe
dingfest machen und dafür sorgen dass
sie ihren fairen beitrag zur
finanzierung des gemeinwesens leisten
christian gentner der
bundesfinanzminister unter anderem zum
in diesen tagen viel diskutierten
sogenannten tank rabatt morgen beginnt
die stunde der wahrheit wirklich mehr
wissen wir dann wahrscheinlich in 34
tagen hier geht's weiter mit harald weil
aus der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin damen und herren und
liebes finanzpolitik geplantes publikum
alle behalten ich frage mich ob er hat
recht nicht mit blick auf den deutschen
finanzminister auf die europäische union
und auch die zentralbank sein zitat
variieren würde bankraub ist eine
unternehmung von dilettanten wahre
profis gründen eine bank und noch wahre
profis kunden eine europäische bank
zentralbank und die ganz ganz waren
profis die machen mehrheitlich ein
bundeshaushalt
seit über einem jahrzehnt kann man das
untersuchungs projekttitel ist nicht von
mir deutschland zahlmeister der eu von
professor emeritus franz heinrich
villiger uni heidelberg fortschreiben
mit diesen sowie eigenen recherchen kann
man folgende feststellung treffen
erstens kann wohl nicht bezweifelt
werden dass eine laufende umverteilung
zwischen verschiedenen mitgliedstaaten
ein wesentliches merkmal der eu ist die
eu samt vorläufern stellt somit schon
lange eine transfer union dar
zweitens die europäische kommission hat
erstmalig so viel zeit hatte man 2006
rückwirkend für die jahre ab 76 daten zu
den einnahmen und ausgaben der eu
veröffentlicht die erlauben das erstmals
aussagen über die nettobeiträge und
nettoleistung zu machen und man kann
konstatieren schon in den 15 jahren vor
der wiedervereinigung zahlte deutschland
60 prozent aller nettoleistung
drittens in den ersten 20 jahren der
wiedervereinigung 1 9 2011 zahlte
deutschland fast 250 milliarden als
gesamtbelastung des haushalts an die eu
vorletztes jahr lagen wir bei ca 20
milliarden netto und jetzt geht sogar
mit 30 milliarden weiter jährlich
weitere eu eigenmittel zöllen abgaben
kommen hinzu und weitere werden erfunden
zitierte eine zusätzliche quelle
deutschland zahlte auch innerhalb der
nettozahler 61 milliarden mehr als ein
angemessener nettobeitrag gewesen wären
deutschland wurde regelrecht
ausgeplündert so der wissenschaftler
willige zitat ende
eben war noch die rede von 60 milliarden
die fehlten sind also schon längst
woanders hingegangen unterm strich gilt
deutschland gesamt beitrag zu der eu
beträgt zwischen 40 und 50 prozent und
das vor dem hintergrund dass der
deutsche anteil am sozialprodukt des
brüsseler eu europas niemals mehr als
ein viertel von dessen sozialprodukt und
bevölkerung ausgemacht hat ich komme zum
schluss die jährlich zig milliarden
zahlungen aus dem bundeshaushalt wachsen
seit dem dritten abgangs sprungartig an
und all die zusätzlichen fonds und
haftungsrisiken die quasi gratis kredite
ohne sicherheiten haben die
billionengrenze längst überschritten sie
stellen immer mehr eine bloße wechsel
reiterei und konkursverschleppung da die
gegenleistung dafür erinnert bestenfalls
an eine leistungsschwache wenn ich gab
betrügerische
versicherungsgesellschaft deren prämien
ständig steigen und wurde er immer
teurer bezahlte versicherungsfall oder
leistungsfall stets weg geleugnet oder
umgangen wird die effektive außen
grenzsicherung sowie vertragstreue und
rechtssicherheit und bürgerliche
freiheitsrechte mit und ohne corona es
ist insbesondere für deutschland eher
ein einziges angebot zur ausbeutung
stadt wohlstandsmehrung bereiten mit dem
am ende konstruktiv rät willeke 0,2
prozent des bruttonationaleinkommens
reichen auf deutsch übersetzt und hier
und jetzt die hälfte der über weicht aus
und es können sogar noch die gleichen
nettoleistung an die nettoempfänger
ausgezahlt werden halbieren sie diese
kosten dann haben wir 20 milliarden
zusätzlich zur verfügung dankeschön
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die spd fraktion dr
thorsten rudolph
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister liebe kollegin
den prognosen sind schwierig sagt ein
bonmot besonders wenn sie die zukunft
betreffen
das gilt in normalen zeiten
aber die zeiten sind nicht normal
wie schlimm wird die nächste corona
welle wie geht es mit dem ukraine krieg
weiter wie mit den locker und sind china
und den schiffen vor shanghai was heißt
das alles für die lieferketten und die
versorgung der welt mit lebensmitteln
und rohstoffen wie geht es mit der
inflation weiter und so weiter und so
fort sicher ist aktuell nur dass nichts
sicher ist deshalb dass die ampel
koalition so wichtig mit diesem haushalt
2022 stabilität zu gewährleisten und
gestaltungsspielraum zu bewahren mit
weiteren umfassenden kroner hilfen mit
den beiden entlastungs paketen für die
bürger innen in höhe von insgesamt 30
milliarden euro mit rekord investitionen
in klima wende digitalisierung bildung
verkehr und sozialen wohnungsbau sven
christian kindler als eben ausgeführt
und natürlich mit zusätzliche
finanzielle hilfe für die ukraine mit
unterstützung für die geflüchteten mit
mehr humanitärer hilfe und mit mitteln
für unsere am stärksten vom krieg
betroffenen unternehmen allein diese
zusätzlichen mittel wegen des krieges
schlagen mit knapp 40 milliarden euro zu
buche ansonsten aber entspricht die
verschuldung mit 99,7 milliarden euro
dem was schon die große koalition im
ersten regierungsentwurf vorgesehen
hatte nicht schön aber eben das ergebnis
der außergewöhnlichen notsituationen im
sinne von artikel 115 grundgesetz in der
wir uns eben befinden und die dieses
hohe haus zu recht festgestellt hat
gerade weil diese haushalten maß und
mitte heldt ist es ein kluger auszeit
meine damen und herren der auf die
herausforderungen reagiert aber eben
zugleich spielräume lässt dieser
haushalt meine damen und herren ist
finanziell verantwortungsvoll und stoppt
soliden
cdu und csu und ihren vertretern ist das
nicht genug habe ich gelesen fordern
massive mehrausgaben sollen die
mehrwertsteuer senken auf strom gas und
fernwärme die netzentgelte senken die
kalte progression ausgleichen
garantierte zinsen bei der
altersvorsorge zahlen die grenzwerte
beim arbeitnehmer sparbetrag bei der
arbeitnehmer sparzulage verdoppeln den
sparerpauschbetrag verdoppeln den
erstmaligen erwerb selbstgenutzter
immobilien fördern eine
sonderabschreibung für energieeffiziente
wohngebäude einführen den
verteidigungshaushalt kontinuierliche
aufwachsen lassen und nicht zu vergessen
natürlich den solidaritätszuschlag für
die oberen zehn prozent
abschaffen allein diese letzte maßnahme
kostet 11 milliarden euro und das jahr
für jahr ich bin beeindruckt der kollege
mittelberg wie sie auf der ausgabenseite
arbeiten alles in allem meine damen und
herren wird das eine regelrechte
schuldenorgie was sie vorschlagen
liebe kolleginnen dass sie nur die
ausgabenwünsche der letzten zwei drei
monate ohne jeden anspruch auf
vollständigkeit ich habe einfach schnell
wieder aufgehört zu recherchieren weil
ich angst hatte meine ganze redezeit für
zusatzaufgaben der union auch drauf geht
das beste daran ist aber die union
beklagt zugleich ständig dass die ampel
angeblich rekordschulden machen also die
schulden die die cdu/csu selbst in der
großen koalition beschlossen hat und die
knapp 40 milliarden zusätzlich für die
ukraine die im großen und ganzen
unstrittig sind muss sagen ich habe
schon einen gewissen respekt vor so viel
unverfrorenheit cdu/csu greifen verbal
ungeniert in den staatssäckel und rufen
dabei zugleich haltet den dieb
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich will
nicht unterschlagen dass die union auch
einmal beträge sparen will
beispielsweise die zweieinhalb
milliarden euro für das neue euro ticket
750 millionen bei der dekarbonisierung
der wirtschaft 50 millionen bei der
querschnittsaufgabe energieeffizienz und
natürlich die 60 milliarden euro für den
energie und klimafonds ist ein christian
kindler hat alles dazu gesagt alle diese
vorschläge zusammen ergeben ein präzises
bild welche politik die union will
entlastungen für wohlhabende weniger
geld für die energie verkehrswende viel
weniger geld für die klimawende dafür
aber die ich lese gerne atomkraft und
schrecken viele erkennen hier schon
deutlich die handschrift von friedrich
merz fest steht jedenfalls kolleginnen
und kollegen das ist politik für die
80er jahre nicht für die 2020
damen und herren die ampel macht politik
für die 2020er jahre zum glück auch wenn
die bedingungen zur zeit alles andere
als einfach sind sie haben
wahrscheinlich gestern auch alle gelesen
dass eine ifo studie noch in diesem jahr
einen preisanstieg bei den lebensmittel
um weitere zehn prozent erwartet und wir
wissen alle dass steigende
lebensmittelpreise und energiepreise
gerade menschen mit geringem einkommen
besonders hart treffen lassen sie es
mich der daher hier von diesem pult aus
ganz deutlich sagen wir lassen niemanden
im stich wir beobachten die lage sehr
genau und werden gegebenenfalls
reagieren und weitere entlastung
beschließen diese koalition hat gezeigt
dass sie auch kurzfristig handlungsfähig
ist
meine damen und herren wir wissen alle
nicht wie es weitergeht mit krieg
pandemie und inflation eines wissen wir
aber jetzt schon wir wissen dass die
energiepreise dauerhaft hoch bleiben
werden die zeiten billigen gases aus
russland sind vorbei die energiewende
kommt mit einem schnellen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien einer konsequenten
co2 bepreisung und wir wissen auch und
zwar jetzt schon dass die energiewende
nur dann ein erfolg wird wenn sie kein
eliten projekt bleibt und deshalb finde
ich den vorschlag von hubertus heil ein
sozial gestaffeltes klima geld
einzuführen auch so gut und so wichtig
wir brauchen eine dauerhafte und
gezielte entlastung bei den
energiepreisen für alle mit geringen und
mittleren einkommen diejenigen die es am
nötigsten brauchen sollen am meisten
bekommen dies nicht ganz so nötig haben
bekommen etwas und die viel verdienen
bekommen nichts genau umgekehrt verhält
es sich übrigens wenn wir stattdessen
die einkommenssteuer senken denn die
geringverdiener zahlen keine
einkommenssteuer und bekommen dann
nichts die wenig verdienen bekommen
etwas und die vielverdiener bekommen am
meisten deshalb kolleginnen kollegen bin
ich froh dass das klima im
koalitionsvertrag steht steuersenkungen
aber nicht
wenn damit herrn wir haben in frankreich
gesehen wo marie le pen die
lebenshaltungskosten gezielt
instrumentalisiert hat wohin das führt
das sollte auch uns in deutschland klar
sein eine klima wende ohne sozialen
ausgleich wird es nicht geben klima
wende ist keine aufgabe für ein oder
zwei legislaturperioden und wer
dauerhaft eine politische mehrheit für
eine wirkliche klimawandel wer die
gesellschaft zusammenhalten will bei der
großen transformation der muss die
menschen mitnehmen das ist die aufgabe
kolleginnen kollegen ich verspreche
ihnen die spd fraktion wird alles dafür
tun diese aufgabe zu erfüllen ärzten
kann
thorsten rudolph für die spd fraktion in
dieser debatte des deutschen bundestages
die die haushaltswoche eröffnet das geht
im großen und ganzen um die
finanzpolitik im allgemeinen aber ganz
nebenbei in anführungszeichen auch um
den etat des bundesfinanzministers
nächster redner ist christian görke aus
der linksfraktion wo er
finanzpolitischer sprecher ist und er
war von 14 bis 19 finanzminister in
brandenburg der koalition ist eine
einzige fingerhakeleien und er ist auch
unehrlich 100 milliarden sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr 40 milliarden euro
ergänzungs haushalt alles an der
schuldenbremse vorbei getrickst und wenn
sie schon meine damen und herren von der
koalition mit der cdu an das grundgesetz
gehen um ihren aufrüstung waren
abzusichern dann haben sie die mut diese
schuldenbremse zu reformieren und zwar
mit einer goldenen regel dass auch in
zukunft noch investitionen in
klimaschutz und vor allen dingen auch in
die verkehrswende enkel gerecht
realisiert werden können und sehr
geehrter herr bundes finanzminister
interessant war ja eben ihre these dass
die rückkehr zur schuldenbremse und eine
sparpolitik die inflation senken wird
dabei ist die sparpolitik der
vergangenheit eine ursache für diese
inflation dass wir so unabhängig sind
voll von diesen energieimporten dass wir
bei den erneuerbaren und auch bei der
verkehrswende längst nicht da sind wo
wir sein müssten und außerdem der
finanzminister gehen sie wieder mal vom
wachstum wo soll er denn herkommen solle
vom himmel fallen wenn sie nächstes jahr
die schuldenbremse einführen
ziehen sie die handbremse an dieser
konjunktur und die logik es ganz einfach
wenn sie ab 20 23
132 milliarden euro weniger ausgeben
dann heißt das
132 milliarden weniger für investitionen
132 milliarden einnahmen weniger den
wirtschaftskreislauf und zuzüglich die
abrissbirne an den sozialstaat sofern
sie nicht endlich ob steuern und vor
allen dingen diese exorbitanten und die
zahlen recht über einiger weniger in
deutschland endlich enkel gerecht
besteuern und meine damen und herren
unsere vorschläge für eine
vermögensabgabe zur verbesserung der
einnahmen der bundeshaushalt blick auf
dem tisch die gewerkschaften begrüßen
dass und deshalb meine damen und herren
von spd und auch grünen machen sie sich
endlich ehrlich und steuern sie im
wahrsten sinne des wortes um und lassen
sie sich nicht weiter von diesem
finanzminister mit dem nasenring durch
die steuerpolitische manege ziehen und
sehr geehrter herr kindler sie haben zu
recht gesagt man muss immer korrigieren
deshalb noch einmal ein dringender
appell an die ampeln korrigieren sie
ihre unsägliche entscheidung zur
energieforschung
denn es ist unakzeptabel dass sogar
jetzt der kanzler und die mitglieder
dieser bundesregierung diese pauschale
bekommen die rentnerinnen und rentner
und die studenten wie bekanntlich
ausgeben korrigieren sie das vielen dank
christian görke für die linksfraktion
und ihm wird jetzt folgen
[Musik]
stimmt gar nicht der nächste redner ist
nämlich andreas dresch für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen war seit kurzem
auch stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender ist in der
nachfolge von dieser paus die jetzt
ministerin ist sehr geehrte damen und
herren
als wir unseren koalitionsvertrag mit
der überschrift mehr fortschritt wagen
überschrieben haben da wussten wir dass
wir für fortschritt investieren müssen
und genau das tun wir jetzt mit diesem
haushalt
2022 wir starten eine investition zu
offen sie wird zum beispiel mit den 60
milliarden zusätzlich im klima- und
transformations- vor ort die humanitäre
hilfe liegt mit 27 milliarden euro auf
rekordniveau und für den sozialen
frieden in deutschland bringen wir
angesichts von 7,9 prozent fossile
inflation mehr als 40 milliarden euro in
den entlastungs paketen auf
das ist gut und das richtig investiert
das geld jeder euro den wir heute in den
ausbau erneuerbarer energien stecken
der wird uns frei machen und er wird uns
unabhängig machen von diktatoren wie
wladimir putin die mit der
preistreiberei politik machen und wir
dürfen uns keine illusionen hingeben im
moment nutzt putin korn und getreide als
warf er wird im herbst auch das als
waffe nutzen und deswegen müssen wir
auch an der stelle investieren um
wegzukommen von interessierten systemen
wir müssen jeden euro in klimaschutz
investieren weil wir damit katastrophen
wie im aartal verhindern milliarden über
milliarden kostet das jetzt auch zu
räumen wenn wir investieren dann haben
wir die andere logik nicht klimaschutz
zu betreiben ist das teuerste was wir
tun können das dürfen wir künftigen
generationen nicht aufbürden deswegen
müssen wir jetzt investieren und die 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr die
sind gut für die verteidigungsfähigkeit
deswegen werde ich am freitag zustimmen
aber sie sind angesichts der
klimakatastrophe und angesichts der
sozialen fragen keine ausreichend der
antwort auf die größte herausforderungen
die wir in diesem land haben das sehen
übrigens nicht nur wir so das sieht auch
die europäische kommission so deswegen
hat sie beschlossen auf 2023 die
schuldenregeln noch einmal ausgesetzt zu
lassen weil es um verantwortung geht in
einer krisensituation weil es um
verantwortung geht die größer ist als
die schuldenbremse weil es um
die ideologie einer schwarzen null eine
verantwortung der wir uns auch hier in
deutschland stellen werden
und das gilt auch für die steuerpolitik
lassen sie uns darüber reden herr
lindner dass wir kleine und mittlere
einkommen in der einkommensteuer
entlasten das können wir gerne machen
aber völlig klar ist doch dabei auch
dass wir gleichzeitig auch darüber reden
müssen den spitzensteuersatz dann
anzuheben nur das macht sind nur das
können nur dann wir gemeinsam über eine
reform an der stelle reden mehr
investieren gleichzeitig mindereinnahmen
in kauf zu nehmen und gleichzeitig keine
schulden zu machen das zusammen
funktioniert nicht das passt nicht
zusammen schon rechnerisch nicht
deswegen ist es aufgabe
deswegen ist es aufgabe für den haushalt
2023 und die beratungen das stimmig zu
machen genau dass es aufgabe der
verhandlungen 23 und dieser
verantwortung werden wir uns als ampel
angesichts der großen krisen und
herausforderungen dieser zeit stellen
herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
dr carsten bresser
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in diesem monat veröffentlichte
das bundesfinanzministerium ein
bemerkenswertes strategie papier unter
dem titel finanzpolitik in der
zeitenwende wachstum stärken und
inflationäre impulse vermeiden dort
heißt es unter anderem es brauche eine
finanzpolitik die effizient und
vorausschauend agiert effizient bedeute
nach ihrer auffassung ausgaben
fortlaufend zu priorisieren und zu
evaluieren sie herr lindner fordert
ferner finanzpolitische verlässlichkeit
und die schnelle wiedereinführung der
schuldenbremse und sie wollen
öffentliche investitionen gegenüber
zusätzlichen sozialausgaben priorisieren
das alles sind beeindruckende aussagen
die auch aus der feder von ludwig erhard
stammen könnten doch die von ihnen
genannten ansprüche entsprechen leider
nicht der finanzpolitischen realität
ihre bekenntnisse sowie der einführung
der schuldenbremse suggerieren der
bundeshaushalt sei ein hort der
stabilität doch das gegenteil ist der
fall noch nie in der geschichte unseres
landes war die bundesrepublik so hoch
verschuldet wie heute und sie wollen
diese schulden noch mal um 139
milliarden euro erhöhen wer im sinne von
prioritätensetzungen nach einsparungen
sucht sucht leider vergebens anstatt den
beamtenapparat des gesamten bundes
abzuspecken schaffen sie 9600
zusätzliche stellen ihre ausgabenplanung
beläuft sich mittlerweile auf sage und
schreibe 4 196 milliarden euro jeden
vierten ausgegebenen euro finanzieren
sie durch neue schulden die
gesamtwirtschaftliche verschuldung die
gesamtstaatliche verschuldung steigt
damit auf 2,4 billionen euro das sind
29.000 euro pro bundesbürger vom kind
bis zur rentnerin pro sekunde erhöht
sich der schuldenstand um weitere 4900
euro
länder sie bekennen sich zu schnellen
wie der einführung der schuldenbremse
das ist gut aber in wahrheit war bereits
im nachtragshaushalt 20 21 der anfang
vom ende der schuldenbremse in den
jahren 2020 bis 2022 wird allein der
bund 485 milliarden neue schulden
gemacht haben denn dazu ursprünglich ab
2023 beginnenden tilgungsplan haben sie
kurzerhand auf 2.028 verschoben die
türken auch nicht mehr innerhalb von 20
jahren wie es ursprünglich beschlossen
wurde sondern sie strecken die
rückzahlung auf 30 jahre und schieben
das ist auch das jahr 2058 hinaus
gegenüber unseren kindern und enkeln ist
eine solche finanzpolitik weder
nachhaltig noch sozial denn nicht unsere
generation doch diese schon zurückzahlen
sondern die kommende generation wird die
hauptlasten tragen müsse herr
finanzminister die politischen und
finanziellen gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
generation zukünftiger generationen
schwinden damit immer weiter wenn sie
nicht schleunigst eine schubumkehr
einleiten umso bemerkenswerter ist es
dass sie in ihrem papier selbst zu der
erkenntnis kommen dass man den
ökonomisch unsicheren zeiten keine
sozialpolitischen leistungen erhöhen
sollte aber genau das bereiten sie
gerade vor sie entwickeln ein bürgergeld
das den bundeshaushalt noch mal
milliarden kosten wird und auf dem weg
dorthin schaffen sie mal eben sämtliche
sanktionen ab die bisher zur
leistungskürzung aufgrund der verletzung
von mitwirkungspflichten führen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
sozialleistungen bezieht für den gibt es
auch die verpflichtung zur mitwirkung
diese ist unverzichtbar denn solidarität
ist keine einbahnstraße und der
sozialstaat wird von den menschen
getragen die jeden tag zur arbeit gehen
lindner wollen den prinzipien der
haushaltswahrheit und haushaltswaren
wieder stärker geltung verschaffen das
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich
gleichzeitig erkennen sie dass der
demografische wandel die
sozialversicherungssysteme zunehmend
unter druck setzt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der steuerzuschuss zur
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung bereiche
in diesem jahr bereits einen wert von
über 100 milliarden euro die gesetzliche
kranken- und pflegeversicherung
benötigen ebenfalls zuschüsse aus dem
bundeshaushalt sie herr lindner erkennen
selbst dass das demographische risiko
den handlungsspielraum des
bundeshaushalts weiter einschränkt aber
die implizite deckung der
verbindlichkeiten der sozialversicherung
ist eine schwebende schuld in unserem
haushalt die jetzt angegangen werden
muss anstatt zügig über notwendige
formen zu entscheiden planen sie den
einstieg in eine kapitalgedeckte säule
zur stabilisierung der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung gut
zehn milliarden euro sollten dafür im
aktuellen haushalt eigentlich
bereitgestellt werden bei einer
angenommenen verzinsung von
beispielsweise sechs prozent würde
dieser fonds also 600 millionen euro per
anno wirtschaften viel geld glaubt man
aber das entspricht lediglich 0,2
prozent der beitragseinnahmen des
letzten jahres eine begrüßenswerte aber
leider nur homöopathische entlastung und
weit entfernt von einem notwendigen
reformpaket doch selbst dieses minimal
vor sucht man ihrem aktuellen haushalt
leider vergebens seger der
bundesfinanzminister auch die
finanzpolitik ist in einer zeitenwende
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt geeignete
und mutige entscheidung mit
entsprechender größe wenn sie als
ampelkoalition wachstum stärken
inflationäre impulse vermeiden und die
sozialversicherungssysteme stabilisieren
wollen dann müssen sie ihre selbst
formulierten ansprüche auch den
realitäten entsprechen vielen dank
kastenbrot es für die unionsfraktion die
ja der meinung ist dass es so viele
schulden nicht gebraucht hätte für viele
neue schulden für diesen bundeshaushalt
wenn man beispielsweise auf die eine
oder andere rücklage verzichtet
beziehungsweise sie aufgelöst hätte otto
fricke ist der nächste redner der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion
fest zweiten was diese
koalitionsgespräche im thema haushalt
und die verhandlung im
haushaltsausschuss ausgemacht haben ist
eigentlich fast unmöglich dennoch will
ich mal eine sache für diese koalition
voranstellen ein haushalt ist nichts
anderes als der inbegriff des
kompromisses den eine koalition treffen
muss da findet sich jeder aber jeder
auch nicht und ich möchte mich
ausdrücklich bei den beiden
koalitionspartnern bedanken mit ihren
arbeitsgruppen dass wir diesen haushalt
so hinbekommen haben wie wir ihn in
diesen schwierigen zeiten auch ihm
bekommen musste meine damen und herren
wir haben dabei auch die
parlamentsrechte gestärkt ich komme
gleich noch dazu zu der frage anträge
aber wir haben auch dafür gesorgt dass
wir nicht mitbekommen haben dass wir
selbst bei der frage das
beschaffungswesen schon eine erste
gesetzliche regelung vorgenommen haben
die dafür sorgt dass der
haushaltsausschuss und damit das
parlament bei der frage wer beschaffung
im militärwesen zukünftig an der
explizit starke rolle spielen wird wir
werden das wahrscheinlich am freitag
noch einmal verstärken dafür groß sei
dank denn es ist am ende wichtig dass
beim thema haushalt klar ist dass die
bundesregierung nur das machen kann was
das parlament als erst gewalt ihr auch
sagt dass es zu tun hat beziehungsweise
dass sie es tun kann das wiederum meine
damen und herren
habe ich so das gefühl
ist etwas was in den nächsten jahren auf
uns noch ein weiterer arbeit zu kommen
denn wir müssen erkennen wir können
nicht einfach immer nur leistungsgesetze
ausbauen wir müssen auch immer noch in
der gesamtwürdigung sehen dass diese
leistungsgesetze an die jeweiligen
realitäten sich anpassen das heißt dann
nicht weil eine fdp das sagt es geht um
kürzungen sondern heißt dann genau dass
man gucken muss wo es notwendig es ist
angesprochen worden und ich sage das
auch jetzt schon in richtung cdu csu wir
haben eine sozialleistung ausdrücklich
gestärkt die künstlersozialkasse und
zwar deswegen weil wir erkannt haben
dass wir hier den schwächsten helfen
müssen und dass ihr andere
voraussetzungen in der krise in der
kroner krise galten als sie vorher warnt
abgelehnt worden ist diese erhöhung von
einer fraktion von der cdu/csu das ist
das wo ich dann immer sagen da zeigt
sich wie diese ampel wird man macht
kompromisse man stärkt den sozialen
bereich aber man weiß auch wo die
grenzen sind und mehr im weg der
minister hat das schon zu den ställen im
zoll gesagt die sie nicht haben wollen
es ist schon gesagt und zu den ställen
beim bundeskriminalamt die sie nicht
haben wollen jetzt gehe ich noch mal in
die von china angeblich so hohe stelen
hin da ist und krieg in der ukraine da
sind kriegsverbrecher die wollen wir
verfolgen mit generalbundesanwalt mit
bundesgerichtshof das sind bestellen
wollen sie die nicht oder sagen sie nein
das sind stellen die auch punkt der
gegenwärtigen situation notwendig sind
und wir als cdu haben uns geirrt dass
wir bei diesen stellen nicht mitgemacht
haben das wäre sehr gut wenn sie das an
der stelle
[Applaus]
so und meine damen und herren ich will
zum schluss noch etwas sagen weil es
einfach auf mich ärgert bei der cdu/csu
man könnte jetzt keiner stelle sagen
viel lärm um nichts aber ich will ihnen
das deutlich sagen zum ersten mal seit
16 jahren ist es so dass es der
opposition nicht gelungen ist mehr
änderungen am haushalt durch anträge
vorzunehmen als der koalition sie haben
es als cdu noch nicht einmal geschafft
halb so viele anträge zu stellen wie wir
es als fdp noch in der letzten
legislatur jedes jahr getan haben und
darum es zum schluss zu sagen und der
rest ist dann nach schicks wir schweigen
es war der cdu csu nicht möglich selbst
einem konzept wirkungsorientierte
haushaltsführung beim bmf zuzustimmen
das wollen sie nicht überlegen sie sich
ob es beim nächsten mal besser machen
jedenfalls müssen sie es besser machen
als in dieser links hatte
otto fricke aber dass der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion und wenn sich hier die ganze
debatte über den gesamten zeitraum
verfolgt haben dann fällt auf dass es
insbesondere fdp und unions redner sind
die sich hier aneinander reiben was den
haushalt angeht und was nicht
stattgefunden hat aus sicht der
unionsfraktion michael schrodi ist der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion
zahlen zuletzt geliefert 44 milliarden
prognostiziert
mehreinnahmen höhere steuereinnahmen im
vergleich zur letzten steuerschätzung am
20 21
und man muss das schon mal auch deutlich
sagen ich glaube das ist bei aller
harten debatte im detail schon ein
ergebnis einer richtigen krisenpolitik
der letzten jahre gewesen mit
wirtschaftshilfen corona steuer hilfe
gesetzen kurzarbeitergeld
direktzahlungen die firmenpleiten sind
ausgeblieben der arbeitsmarkt ist robust
gerade die neuen zahlen dass die
arbeitslosigkeit auch im mai wieder
gesunken ist und grundlage waren dafür
und sind dafür die massiven
hilfsprogramme investitionen die 20 und
zwar an sich auch die union begrüßt hat
die auch in vielen stellen die
unterstützung hier im gesamten parlament
gefunden haben und ich glaube es ist
wichtig zu erwähnen dass der weg der
damals richtig war auch heute weiterhin
richtig ist und auf diesen weg begeben
wir uns auch mit diesem haushalt
persönlich zahlen sind muss man auch
sagen sind natürlich höchst volatil
unsicher wir wissen nicht wie es mit
kriegen pandemie mit der importierten
inflation mit hohen energiepreisen und
lieferketten störungen weiter geht wie
sich wirtschaft entwickelt die
steuereinnahmen sich dann noch
entwickeln eines hakens in dieser krise
weiterhin und dieser herausforderungen
weiterhin was auch olaf scholz gesagt
hat wir lassen niemanden alleine nicht
die bürgerinnen und bürger und auch
nicht die unternehmen in dieser krise
das heißt der finanzpresse dreiklang
unserer applikation heißt sozialen
zusammenhalt stärken
zukunftsinvestitionen weiterhin anpacken
und für eine solide finanzierung sorgen
und diese haushalt bündelt all das genau
und deswegen ist er auch so zu
unterstützt meine sehr geehrten damen
kann
ich glaub hatte tieren aus der debatte
zum haushalt 20 21 da hat die union der
fraktionsvorsitzende da was ralph
brinkhaus überschrift gewählt mit mut
die krise überwinden und gesagt auch
neue schulden müssen aufgenommen werden
um die folgen der krise abzufedern und
in die weiche und die weichen für die
zukunft zu stellen damals war 42
milliarden wir haben zu einer milliarden
euro weniger aber was richtig damals war
ist es jetzt auch der hausherr 2022 tut
genau das auch richtig zu investieren
übrigens auch und es verwundert mich
otto fricke hat gesagt der finanzmärkte
gesagt
wie kommt es bitteschön zu dieser
massiven kritik an einem stellenaufbau
beim zoll
bei der finanzkontrolle schwarzarbeit
bei der bekämpfung der geldwäsche der
zur kriminalität das von der union ist
nicht
nachvollziehbar
und das zweite ist heraus da würde ich
aus sicht eines csu das und aus bayern
kommend wirklich ganz ruhig sein
die stellen bei der steuer fahren
darüber eine betriebsprüfung da ist grad
bayern ganz weit hinten dran das ist
nicht nur ungerecht sie verzichten auf
steuereinnahmen zu ungunsten der
bayerischen steuerzahler den
steuerzahler und bürger verstoß
tatsächlich
gestalten wir eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen aus der cdu-fraktion von
henneberg
schrodi dass sie die zwischenfrage zu
lassen wenn sie meinen beitrag
sorgfältig zugehört haben habe ich den
stellenaufbau den zusätzlichen von 6000
stellen netto nicht pauschal kritisiert
ich habe das angesprochen habe gesagt
über die dinge kann man den einzelnen
reden trotzdem ist es insgesamt ein
bemerkenswerter aufbau und den muss man
infrage stellen meine frage an sie ist
es denn richtig und das habe ich auch
angesprochen dass sie bei der
einstellung zusätzlicher spitzenbeamten
in den ministerien nicht in
irgendwelchen gerichten irgendwelche b
besoldeten richter sondern in den
ministerien mit 324 stellen den rekord
jetzt setzen und ist es richtig dass sie
mit 37 parlamentarischen
staatssekretären hochbezahlt
regierungsbeamte jetzt auch einen
rekordwert setzen ist das richtig und
können sie mir das bestätigen
herr mittelberg zunächst einmal ist es
ja schön wenn sie hier in ihrer rede
haben sie das nicht getan
differenzieren und wenn sie auch ein
licht an deutlich machen dass es richtig
ist dass wir in dem bereich in dem
einiges getan werden muss nämlich bei
dem bereich steuer bekämpfung
betrugsbekämpfung dass wir den zoll
stärken dass wir hier für mehr
steuergerechtigkeit sorgen übrigens
etwas was im koalitionsvertrag explizit
festgehalten ist dass wir hier etwas tun
wollen beispielsweise auch beim thema
des umsatzsteuerbetrugs dass wir hier
einen stellenaufbau haben der richtig
und notwendig ist zum einen und zum 2
wir haben in dieser koalition eine
fortschritts koalition auf den weg
gebracht die deutlich macht wir wollen
große aufgaben angehen und die
ministerien und alles was dazu notwendig
ist muss ordentlich ausgestattet sein
dazu gehört auch eine personelle
ausstattung die wir diesen haushalt auch
gewährleistet ist insofern ist das
richtig dass wir in diesen zeiten gut
ausgestattete ministerien haben wir die
großen aufgaben die zukunftsaufgaben
angehen können und deswegen sind die
investitionen auch das kanal hier
richtig vermittelt
übrigens der haushalt tut auch das was
wichtig ist beim thema investitionen 51
milliarden euro im haushalt sind nach
einem zusätzlichen investitionen
enthalten denn
nur wer heute investiert in bildung in
weiterbildung nur wenn die bahn wäre
wohnungsbau wer in die erneuerbaren
energien
investiert der schafft die voraussetzung
dafür dass wir auch in zukunft
zukunftsfähige unternehmen haben die
arbeitsplätze der zukunft haben und
damit auch die steuereinnahmen von
morgen entsprechend haben auch das ist
eben ein wichtiger beitrag für solide
finanzen der zukunft wenn wir heute
investieren zahlt sich das auch in
zukunft aus und gleichzeitig stellen wir
mit dem haushalt auch inflationsbedingte
mehrausgaben da die haushalte mit
kleinen mittleren einkommen sind am
härtesten betroffen von den
preissteigerungen wir haben mit den
leistungspaketen 1 und 2 wir haben mit
dem vierten grüner steuer hilfe gesetzt
von den 44 milliarden mehreinnahmen die
auf zitiert werden allein schon 42
milliarden euro tiefe da an hilfen für
bürgerinnen und bürger für unternehmen
zurück geben und sie gezielt gerade für
kleinere mittlere einkommen zur
verfügung stellen damit wir die hohen
kosten auch abdämpfen für die die es am
härtesten trifft und das ist gut
investiertes geld in den sozialen
zusammenhalt meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren
dass der weiteren tun wir beobachten die
situation und die entwicklung weiter wir
werden schauen ob wir weitere hilfen
auch auf den weg bringen müssen 1 bleibt
aber klar auch in zukunft der dreiklang
der heiß sozialer zusammenhalt
investitionen möglich machen und darauf
zu nie die finanzen auch schaffen und
mit diesen dreiklang werden wir auch in
den nächsten wochen monate gehen vielen
dank
michael schrodi für die spd-fraktion und
jetzt hat es auch mal zwischen spd und
union gekracht konnte ja nicht
ausbleiben bei diesem thema wir sind in
der allgemeinen finanzdebatte es wird
auch diskutiert über den etat des
bundesfinanzministers und des
bundesrechnungshofs aber im grunde geht
es schon um die ausrichtung der finanz
und haushaltspolitik
insgesamt sebastian schäfer für bündnis
90 die grünen deshalb pult
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen unser land
wurde und wird durch die korona pandemie
und den russischen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine extrem herausgefordert
energiepreise steigen die probleme bei
den lieferketten haben sich noch einmal
verschärft wir sind gesamtwirtschaftlich
leider immer noch nicht auf
vorkrisenniveau angelangt und die
wachstumsprognosen für
2022 wurden teils deutlich nach unten
korrigiert laut dem deutschen industrie
und handelskammertag
beläuft sich der verlust durch die
korona krise bis ende diesen jahres auf
circa 5 145 milliarden euro und das
rechnet die wirtschaftlichen folgen des
brutalen angriffs krieges nicht mit ein
diese töpfe lust entspricht dem volumen
von anderthalb bundes haushalten vor der
krise und die wirtschaftlichen
perspektiven bleiben schwierig
dementsprechend müssen wir weiter auf
sicht fahren und sollten keine maßnahme
vorschnell ausschließen im gegensatz zum
letzten jahrzehnt erleben wir zudem dass
durch steigende zinsen die spielräume im
bundeshaushalt kleiner werden mit dem
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf gelingt es
der fortschritts koalition ein
politikwechsel einzuleiten
wir stabilisieren die investitionen auf
dem rekordniveau kollege tobias
angesprochen wir handeln und bekämpfen
die krisen sind international
verlässliche bündnispartner und stärken
sozialen zusammenhalt und klimaschutz
mit in die zukunft gerichteten
investitionen schaffen wir nachhaltiges
wachstum unternehmerisches sicherheit
und damit auch sichere arbeitsplätze
investitionen in der natürlichen
klimaschutz in elektromobilität in die
dekarbonisierung unserer industrie und
in den wasserstoff standort deutschland
helfen nicht nur dem klima damit
unterstützen wir vor allem auch die
transformation der wirtschaft
wir nehmen in diesem jahr nochmals
rekordschulden auf um die bürgerinnen
und bürger angesichts der
preisentwicklung zu entlasten und unsere
extrem herausgeforderte wirtschaft zu
stützen mit dem sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro wollen wir der
bundeswehr die notwendige ausstattung
zur verfügung stellen insgesamt nehmen
wir neue schulden von fast einer
viertelmillion euro auf nicht
leichtfertig das kann ich unseren
bürgerinnen und bürgern versichern
wir dürfen die fehler der vergangenheit
nicht wiederholen unser staat muss in
den zentralen zukunftsfragen im rahmen
einer ökologisch sozialen
marktwirtschaft auch selbst
verantwortung übernehmen
mit der preisentwicklung insbesondere
bei fossiler energie aber auch bei
lebensmitteln können weitere
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger notwendig werden dabei ist es
zentral dass wir diese entlastungen sehr
zielgenau vornehmen die bisherigen
entlassungen müssen wir kritisch
evaluieren und dann entsprechend handeln
dann wird unser land auch durch diese
schwierigen zeiten kommen herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
christian haase
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt haben wir
es hier schwarz auf weiß 140 milliarden
neue schulden und wenn wir das die
schulden aus dem sondervermögen da noch
zu rechnen würde das ist nicht so ganz
richtig aber die zu rechnen würde dann
hätten wir leider wieder einen
schuldenrekord und er lehnt man das
hätten sie sicherlich zu beginn ihrer
amtsübernahme auch anders vorgestellt
dass sie ihren vorgänger dabei noch
überholen dabei hätte die
steuerschätzung der ampel zu mindestens
mittelfristig die möglichkeit gegeben
für entlastungen der bürgerinnen und
bürger zu sorgen und auch die
neuverschuldung zu senken was erleben
wir stattdessen im rahmen der
parlamentarischen beratung verteilt die
ampel das geld der steuerzahler
steuerzahler völlig ungeniert die
ausgaben des bundes steigen doch mal um
zwölf milliarden euro
nur damit jeder etwas von seiner
wunschliste streichen kann und auch im
personalhaushalt damals nun mehrfach
darauf hingewiesen wird ordentlich drauf
gesattelt brutto fast 10.000 stellen das
kann es an der stelle nicht sein wenn
wir über zeitenwende sprechen und dieses
wort zeitenwende scheint zumindest bei
den appell koalitionären bisher noch
nicht so angekommen zu sein die
aktuellen krisen und herausforderungen
brauchen eine klare antwort und die
bundesregierung liefert uns dabei leider
nur mittelmäßigkeit
was hatten grüne und fdp vor sie wollten
schattenhaushalte auflösen subventionen
streichen die kalte progression
bekämpfen den mittelstandsbauch
abflachen rücklagen auflösen
privatisierungserlöse erzielen
all das hatten sie noch vor kurzem hier
im bundestag gefordert übrig geblieben
ist die einigkeit beim geldausgeben also
meine damen und herren anspruch und
wirklichkeit
da doch sehr weit auseinander und ich
will noch einmal erklären was den
zeitenwende bedeutet man kann nicht so
weiter machen wie bisher das ist die
aussage von zeitenwende wir hatten
kommen aus einer zweijährigen weltweiten
pandemie wir erleben die rückkehr der
inflation die wirtschaftsleistung
stagniert und wir haben krieg in europa
und leben dies kann politik keine
richtige konkrete entlastung die bei
bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommt ich will
nur als ein beispiel dass neun euro
ticket nehmen zweieinhalb milliarden die
vollkommen verpuffen an der stelle da
wird man keine pendler in den op en v
mit rein bekommen da hätten wir bv
anders helfen können
wie wir nach der gießkanne politik
2023 zu schuldenbremse zurückkommen
wollen das ist mir unergründlich und
trotzdem wir wollen mit dieser
bundesregierung auch unsere
staatspolitische verantwortung zeigen es
mehrfach heute angesprochen worden ich
bin froh dass wir uns beim bundesheer
sondervermögen geeinigt haben denn diese
schulden sind die richtige antwort auf
die wiederherstellung der
verteidigungsfähigkeit in deutschland an
der stelle und deshalb ist es auch
gerechtfertigt diese 100 milliarden
zusätzliche schulden aufzunehmen und wir
erkennen auch an dass es in diesem jahr
noch notwendig war ein letztes und ein
wirklich ein allerletztes mal die
schuldenbremse auszusetzen wir sind mit
der begründung die wir jetzt gelesen
haben nicht ganz einverstanden
insbesondere das thema inflation wird
jetzt alleine aus der ukraine krise her
gelöst das glaube ich ist ein wenig
scheuklappen an der stelle ich glaube
die inflation hat mehr gründe als die
ukraine krise und deswegen müssen wir
aufpassen dass wir da finanzpolitisch
auch letztendlich darauf reagieren aber
wenn der 115 grundgesetz jetzt schon die
möglichkeit lässt über die konjunktur
komponente hinaus schulden aufzunehmen
dann heißt das ja nicht automatisch dass
dann dass man das vollständig machen
muss dass man jede möglichkeit die
dahinter steckt jetzt auch ausnutzen
das hätte man anders lösen können und
dann geht es auch darum dass wir das
finanzgefüge mit den ländern doch mal
wieder in den blick nehmen die länder
schon seit zwei jahren machen
überschüsse während der bund hohe
schulden aufnimmt da hätte ich mehr
ansätze gewünscht wo man dagegen angehen
kann und auch das thema stelle möchte
jetzt hier noch einmal klarstellen war
das heute morgen der schrodi vielleicht
hören sie eben zu heute morgen
wiederholt falsch dargestellt wurde wir
machen den vorschlag ein prozent stellen
einsparen ein prozent stelleneinsparung
und wer unsere anträge gelesen hat wird
auch gelesen haben dass wir zum beispiel
den zoll auch wenn das heute mehrfach
falsch gesagt wurde und das bka von
diesen stellen einsparungen aus melden
und jetzt kollege otto fricke
du hast dich eben beklagt dass wir zu
wenig anträge gestellt hätten und du
siehst die sind dann ja noch nicht mal
gelesen worden also wir wollten auch
nicht überfordern an der stelle weil wir
arbeiten an der stelle mit mehr qualität
und weniger quantität und letzter punkt
noch mal in richtung des kollegen schon
alles gesagt haben die ampel selbst hat
ja den antrag gestellt 0,5 prozent
stellen in den ministerien einzusparen
also insofern auch da vielleicht mal mit
den kollegen noch etwas genauer
abstimmen herr kollege haase erlauben
sie eine zwischenfrage oder bemerkung
von otto fricke
herr kollege hase im ersten danke ich
dass sie ausdrücklich klargestellt haben
dass sie die einprozentige pauschale
stellenkürzungen gemacht haben nachdem
sie gesehen hatten dass die koalition
sich auf die 0,5 geeinigt haben meine
frage ist jetzt aber kann ich aus ihrer
äußerungen ausschließen dass es zutrifft
dass sie ebenso wenige anträge gestellt
haben im vergleich zur opposition und
das schließt die grünen im letzten jahr
ja auch mit 1 und b schließlich dann
daraus dass entgegen der äußerung des
kollegen mittelberg sie sagen also bis
auf 1 die 99 der stellen erhöhung der
koalition sind richtig
also wir machen eine solide politik und
genau wahrscheinlich wie sich die ampel
koalition mit den 0,5 prozent so mal ein
wenig an das thema ran gewagt haben
haben wir uns mit dem 1 prozent rang
gewagt wird noch zwei prozent schreiben
können aber wir sehen ja auch realitäten
an der stelle und es wäre besser gewesen
die stellen erst gar nicht aus zu
bringen oder etwas anderes zu tun an der
stelle das hätte man tun können haben
sie nicht getan aber das ist ja dann
ihre entscheidungen als di 0,5 cent
nachher ein zu einzukassieren
und ich hab da mal im
bundesfinanzministerium nachgefragt wenn
wir schon zusätzliche schulden wegen
corona und das war ja bis zum zweiten
regierungsentwurf der inhalt wenn wir
schon zusätzliche schulden wegen krone
aufnehmen können was ich das denn alles
und ein gutteil haken dran haken dran
haken dran relativ enger zusammenhang
zur corona krise aber auf der liste die
mir dann zur verfügung gestellt wurde
fand ich auch das online zugangs gesetz
mit fast zwei milliarden euro
corona bedingt register modernisierung
mit 48 millionen und flotten
erneuerungsprogramm behörden schiffe 224
millionen da ich schon viel kreativität
beim schuldenmachen gefragt um denn
alles letztendlich mit der korona krise
zu begründen meine damen und herren ich
glaube wir hätten an der stelle mehr
machen können herr meier hat ja eben
richtigerweise gesagt was man an der
stelle alles tut wir wollen die kalte
progression abbauen wir wollen die
energiepreis pauschale auch für rentner
und studenten familienzuschuss auf 200
euro verdoppeln entlastungsbetrag für
alleinerziehende und wie finanzieren wir
das mit der rücklage die jetzt
eingesetzt werden muss denn nicht für
zukünftige neue aufgaben sondern wir
müssen sie jetzt einsetzen und den
bürgerinnen bürger das angesparte geld
zurückgeben und weil sie das ebenso
ausdrücklich gesagt haben gehe ich davon
aus dass nicht nur sie gleich unserem
entschließungsantrag auch zustimmen
werden
und
sie haben jetzt die schwere aufgabe
nächstes jahr tatsächlich die
schuldenbremse einzuhalten das heißt es
ist ja gar nicht nächstes jahr im grunde
ist der haushalt ja schon fast fertig an
der stelle und wir sind darauf gespannt
wie das funktionieren kann wir sehen den
druck wenn ich sehe dass er heil in den
letzten tagen das heute morgen herr
rudolph und herr kindler schon wieder
forderungen an den neuen haushalt
gestellt haben der noch gar nicht
veröffentlicht der autor ist wohl jubelt
ja schon das schuldenbremsen aus auf
europäischer ebene
dann weiß ich dass das eine ganz
schwierige aufgabe wird das auch
tatsächlich durchzuhalten wir wollen das
machen sie haben es letztens noch einmal
wiederholt für sie gilt lieber neue
wahlen als neue schulden und dann warten
wir mal ab dankeschön
christian haase war das der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion einer seiner konkreten
kritikpunkte 6000 stellen in ministerien
und behörden das behagte der union und
auch den anderen oppositionsparteien
nicht so wirklich ein anderes beispiel
sind die kosten für den g 7 gipfel die
war mit 50 millionen veranschlagt jetzt
sind 30 mehr das ganze findet ja im
sommer in schloss elmau stadt und vor
2015 hat es gerade mal 15 millionen
gekostet da fragt man sich natürlich
auch wo das dann herkommt frauke
heiligenstadt ist am pult für die
spd-fraktion woche verabschiedet wird
mein kollege michael schrodi hat das
schon ausgeführt hat einen dreiklang ein
dreiklang aus drei verschiedenen
schwerpunkten einmal die
krisenbewältigung
einmal die
zukunftsinvestitionen und einmal die
förderung des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts und dieser dreiklang macht
das besondere eines solchen haushaltes
aus in der ampel regierung
ich komme gleich auf die einzelnen
punkte noch zu sprechen ich möchte
allerdings weil ihnen den letzten
debattenbeiträgen ja immer darauf
eingegangen wurde was wir ausgeben
einmal die einnahmeseite auch beleuchten
zu den haupteinnahmequellen gehören
einmal die steuern in einem staat und
ich denke dass man auch gerade auch als
letzte rednerin in dieser debatte einmal
alle arbeiten denn in den
finanzverwaltungen und in den
finanzämtern der länder ganz herzlich
danken kann denn die müssen jeden tag
steuer ein
einbeziehen und sie müssen unsere
politischen vorgaben umsetzen
ich danke auch natürlich den
steuerzahlen den bürgerinnen und bürgern
denn sie sind es die dafür sorgen dass
wir gemeinsam unsere aufgaben hier
erledigen können nämlich die wichtigen
staatlichen aufgaben und die sich nicht
darum herum drücken und versuchen
steuern zu hinterziehen
das heißt also steuerehrlichkeit ist
sehr wichtig für unseren staat und dafür
gilt es auch einmal danke zu sagen
ist es zum beispiel auch gut dass wir
die voraussetzungen schaffen um noch
besser steuergerechtigkeit zum
durchbruch zu verhelfen indem wir zb
1400 neue stellen es ist schon ein paar
mal erwähnt wurden für die
zollverwaltung aufgelegt haben das ist
ein kampf für mehr steuergerechtigkeit
gegen geldwäsche gegen kriminalität
gegen terrorismus finanzierung aber und
das sei mir gestattet auch aus der
perspektive der sozialdemokratischen
fraktion hier in diesem haus das
deutlich zu machen auch die zweit und
die finanzkontrolle schwarzarbeit
zuständig dafür dass wir die
durchsetzung des mindestlohns auf den
baustellen und den betrieben
kontrollieren können auch das ist
wichtig der wird im übrigen ab oktober
12 euro betragen und das ist gut so
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
der bund wird in 2022 305 40 milliarden
euro steuern einnehmen das sind immerhin
knapp 17 milliarden euro mehr als noch
vor einem halben jahr geschätzt und die
nettokreditaufnahme wird knapp 140
milliarden euro sein all das sind
immerhin deutlich dessen zahlen als wir
sie noch vor einem halben jahr erwarten
konnten das zeigt dass wir auch viele
wichtige maßnahmen in der pandemie
umgesetzt haben die richtig waren zb das
kurzarbeitergeld damit menschen gar
nicht erst in die entsprechenden
hilfesysteme hinein gerutscht sind das
war wichtig sie standen auch noch sofort
wieder den betrieben nach einem
schnellen aufschwung nachdem
nach der zäsur in der pandemie zur
verfügung wir konnten damit viele
entlassungen vermeiden
die zahlen zeigen auch dass wir mit dem
unternehmens beihilfen richtig gelegen
haben denn auch die schnelle
wirtschaftliche erholung hat dazu
beigetragen dass die steuereinnahmen
deutlich gestiegen sind und dass wir
steuern mehr einnahmen haben und damit
auch die aufgaben des staates schultern
können ist natürlich grundsätzlich
positiv andererseits bereitet und die
steigende inflation sehr große sorgen
die preise für lebensmittel und energie
sind besonders für familien und menschen
mit geringem einkommen so exorbitant
gestiegen dass sie ihnen teilweise nicht
mehr wissen wie sie am ende des monats
mit dem einkommen noch klar kommen
müssen deshalb haben wir zwei
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
und meine sehr verehrten kolleginnen und
kollegen der union das ist da nicht
nichts das sind 30 milliarden euro
entlastungen oder direkte zuschüsse für
menschen mit kleinen mit 1 und das ist
richtig so denn die menschen profitieren
von der senkung der strompreise durch
den wegfall der eeg umlage
sie profitieren von dem tank rabatt sie
profitieren von dem neuen euro ticket
und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
was die cdu alles mit den kosten für das
9 euro ticket finanzieren will in jedem
fall weiß ich aber dass millionen von
bestellungen und besteller das neue euro
ticket schon gelöst haben und deswegen
sagen die wir in dem dieses neuen euro
ticket an und das ist auch richtig so
wir werden
wir werden weiterhin die lage aufmerksam
beobachten und ich bin dem
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil sehr
dankbar dass er am wochenende zu dem
thema eines sozialen klima geldes
vorschläge gemacht hat auch das wird
etwas sein was möglicherweise zur
entlastung in den kommenden monaten wenn
es notwendig ist beitragen kann meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren denn wir
behalten einzelnen blick die menschen
mit mittleren und kleinen einkommen die
sind extrem wichtig bei der betrachtung
der steuerpolitik vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
sagt frauke heiligenstadt warum aus der
spd-fraktion und damit ist diese debatte
beendet es geht um die ein und andere
abstimmung
und zwar zunächst über den einzelplan 08
bundesministerium der finanzen in der
ausschuss fassung wer stimmt für diesen
einzelplan das ist die spd fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen und die fdp
fraktion wäre stimmt dagegen das ist die
fdp fraktion cdu csu und die fraktion
die linke damit ist der einzelplan 08
angenommen wir kommen nun zur abstimmung
über den einzelplan 20 der
bundesrechnungshof wer stimmt für diesen
einzelplan
das sind alle fraktionen gibt es
enthaltungen
gegen stimmen dann ist dieser einzelplan
20 einstimmig angenommen ich rufe nun
auf den einzelplan 25 und das ist der
erfüllt das ministerium für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen wie sie
alle wissen ein neu formiertes
ministerium bis 20 21 war der bereich
bau ja teil des
bundesinnenministeriums jetzt also in
eigenverantwortung bei klara geywitz aus
der spd und eines der großen ziele
dieses ministeriums ist es insgesamt das
insgesamt fünf milliarden euro zur
verfügung haben wird in diesem jahr der
bau von 400.000 neuen wohnungen im jahr
davon 100.000 öffentlich gefördert das
wird schwierig werden sagen experten
wobei es in erster linie nicht am geld
liegt sondern daran dass es an material
fehlt mir aber noch an fachkräften die
das ganze machen sollen markus uhl für
die unionsfraktion ist der erste redner
und polen und im rahmen des einzelpreis
25 des bundesministeriums hier wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen hatten wir
ja eine besonderheit nämlich dass wir
einen haushalt eines neuen ministeriums
zu beraten hatten zum ersten mal seit
1998 gibt es wieder ein eigenständiges
wohnen beziehungsweise bauministerium
und ein eigenes haus ein neues haus ist
natürlich mit allen herausforderungen
verbunden da hakt es verständlicherweise
ende ein oder anderen stelle noch
dennoch möchte ich als
hauptberichterstatter dem haus den
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern sowie
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
für den konstruktiven austausch um die
beratungen danke denn ressort stehen
knapp fünf milliarden euro zur verfügung
größe ausgabe mit einer milliarde euro
ist das baukindergeld das ja die alte
cdu geführte bundesregierung eingeführt
hat meine damen und herren vor dem
hintergrund steigen dann nicht nur
immobilienpreise ist die schaffung von
bezahlbarem wohnraum eine der größten
herausforderung unserer zeit die
stärkung der wohneigentumsbildung und
insbesondere für haushalte mit kindern
ist neben den mietwohnungsbau ein
zentrales instrument und dabei ist klar
die eigenen vier wände sind und bleiben
eine krisenfeste wertanlage und ein
wichtiger bestandteil auch der
persönlichen altersvorsorge
das baukindergeld dass die alte
bundesregierung eingeführt hat ist ein
erfolgsmodell und deshalb geht es auch
darum jetzt zuschauen wie es in zukunft
weitergehen kann das baukindergeld
trifft aus nach willen der ampel soll es
ja auch ein jahr früher auslaufen als
bislang geplant und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass klarheit darüber herrscht
wie das thema wohneigentumsbildung in
zukunft vorangebracht werden soll und
wir haben als union in der
bereinigungssitzung an maßgabe beschluss
vorgelegt der an das erfolgreiche
baukindergeld anknüpft und insbesondere
junge familien beim erwerb ihrer ersten
immobilie unterstützt dem sind sie
leider nicht gefolgt aber
immerhin sie haben sich dazu
durchgerungen die bundesregierung
aufzufordern zeit mal ein konzept zur
förderung des erwerbs von wohneigentum
vorzunehmen vorzulegen und ganz ehrlich
ist es dann auch im bereich der
städtebauförderung gelaufen nachdem die
neue bundesregierung im gegensatz zum
alten entwurf die mittel für die
fortführung des förderprogramms
investitionen in nationale projekte des
städtebaus gestrichen hatte und damit
das bereits begonnene auswahlverfahren
für 2022 abgebrochen werden musste haben
wir
den haushaltsberatungen den antrag
gestellt ein neues förderprogramm für
dieses jahr aufzulegen dem ist die
koalition nun auch in der
bereinigungssitzung gefolgt und damit
ist es möglich dass der bund auch in
zukunft herausragende projekte des
städtebaus und der barkultur mit
besonderer nationaler aber auch
internationaler wahrnehmbarkeit in hohem
innovationspotenzial fordert
und ja zum dritten genau so gelaufen ist
es dann auch bei den mitteln für das
programm altersgerecht umbauen
damit fördert seit 2009 sehr erfolgreich
bauliche maßnahmen in wohngebäuden mit
denen barrieren reduziert wird davon
profitieren alle altersgruppen und
insbesondere ältere menschen wird der
längere verbleibenden altere wird der
längeren verbleib den älteren in den
eigenen vier wänden ermöglicht und für
22 waren zunächst keine neuen mittel
mehr vorgesehen und nachdem wir einen
entsprechenden antrag gestellt haben ist
die ampel dann mit einem eigenen antrag
gekommen wenn auch in geringeren volumen
da aber die mittel häufig vor ablauf des
haushaltsjahres aufgebraucht sind wäre
natürlich ein höherer ansatz hilfreich
gewesen gut nach dem motto gut gedacht
aber schlecht gemacht meine damen und
herren sie sehen damit opposition wird
unsere anträge waren vorbild und sie
waren darüber hinaus auch noch alle
gegenfinanziert
ich fasse zusammen die änderungen der
ampel am ursprünglichen
regierungsentwurf vom vergangenen jahr
sind überschaubar in einigen punkten ist
die ampel unseren vorschlägen gefolgt
insgesamt setzten sie falsche
schwerpunkte sie kürzen sehr
erfolgreichen förderprogramme wie das
zum einbruchschutz unterlassen andere
früher auslaufen sie bleiben hinter den
selbst gesteckten erwartungen ihres
koalitionsvertrags zurück und sie setzen
die schwerpunkte falsch
1500 stellen sind vom alten
bundesbauministerium im
bundesinnenministerium in das neue haus
und das neue gewechselt hinzu kommen
etwa 100 stellen zum aufbau des neuen
hauses und jetzt platz im
parlamentarischen verfahren noch einmal
380 weitere stellen für das ressort dazu
das ist in der relation gesehen einsamer
rekord aller ressorts im bund das ist
fast ein viertel zusätzliches personal
ja meine damen und herren frau
ministerin mit so viel personal dann
muss es ja klappen mit den
ambitionierten projekten wie zum
beispiel beim wohnungsbau personal
sollte ja jetzt genügend dasein vielen
dank
markus uhl war das aus der
unionsfraktion der erste redner in der
debatte über den etat des ministeriums
höhe wohnen stadtentwicklung und
bauwesen und dessen chefin ist da die
zuständige ministerin klara geywitz auf
dem weg zum rednerpult
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren abgeordnete herum sie haben es
erwähnt das erste mal seit 98 gibt es
wieder ein baum in ischia das heißt es
gibt auch das erste mal wieder ein etat
wir haben die wunderbare nummer 25
abbekommen und dieses neu gewordene baby
die etwa 25 der wurde in den
parlamentarischen beratungen von ihnen
vor den berichterstattern vom
haushaltsausschuss noch mal ordentlich
aufgepäppelt dafür meinen herzlichen
dank auch für diese sehr schöne
unterstützung auf dem weg ins leben des
ministeriums das ist nämlich eine
hervorragende grundlage für die
investitionen in vieles in nachhaltiges
bauen in bezahlbaren wohnraum und in
gutes leben in stadt und land und wir
investieren in die zukunft unseres
landes denn jeder euro fördermittel
generiert natürlich weitere private und
öffentliche investitionen
das neue bauministerium ist also vor
allem eine investitions ministerium in
die zukunft der gesellschaft wir setzen
impulse für eine gute konjunktur und für
einen stabilen arbeitsmarkt in
deutschland
der bau bietet eine große zahl von
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten für
fachkräfte in vielen berufszweigen und
wir haben sicherheit geschaffen die
finanzplanung die reicht bis 2025 und
sie zeigt wir sind verlässlicher partner
herzlichen dank auf eine
parlamentarierin und parlamentariern
herr uhl hat es bewegt es war ein
ungewöhnliches startbedingungen für die
haushaltsberatungen mein haus hat
versucht ihre arbeit so gut es geht zu
unterstützen
eines unserer hauptziele ist es mehr
wohnraum zu schaffen vor allem solchen
den sich alle menschen leisten können
herold ist nicht darauf eingegangen aber
einer der großen schwerpunkte ist dass
wir es geschafft haben die mittel des
sozialen wohnungsbaus des wohnungsbaus
deutlich zu stärken bis 2026 werden 14 5
milliarden fließen in den sozialen
wohnungsbau dass es ein großer tag auch
um die knappheit von bezahlbaren
wohnraum in den ballungsgebieten zu
entspannen
wir sorgen dafür auch mit mitteln durch
für alters- und barriere gerechtes
umbauen dass menschen länger in ihren
vier wänden bleiben können und die
haushaltsberatungen haben einen akzent
gesetzt auf den erwerb von
genossenschaftsanteilen
hier ist es im parlamentarischen
verfahren möglich gewesen sechs
millionen euro für diesen wichtigen
bereich einzustellen ich bin sicher dass
wir damit einen deutlichen impuls setzen
werden für gründungen und neubau impulse
und wir haben ja uns im ausschuss
verständigt dass diese bundesregierung
auch eine konzeption für die
eigentumsförderung für die nächsten
haushalt vorlegen wird doch allein geld
baut natürlich keine häuser auch
ministerialbeamte machen das in der
regel nicht wir sind darauf angewiesen
in einem breiten bündnis mit den
akteuren aus bund ländern und kommunen
der bauwirtschaft den gewerkschaften und
der zivilgesellschaft die
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen dass in
deutschland wieder mehr gebaut werden
kann und sie haben die zahlen gehört im
letzten jahr von bauminister seehofer
sind die zahlen nach unten gegangen über
300.000 unter 300.000 wohnungen sind
fertig geworden gleichzeitig haben wir 8
847 1000 wohnungen in der warteschlange
im bau überhang wir müssen also
insgesamt
also die herren müssen sich da gar nicht
auf gegen zahlen sind erst mal zahlen
und zu meiner auch gar nicht schön
überraschungen sind die zahlen im
letzten jahr unter 300.000 gewesen bei
gleichzeitig ganz ganz großen zahlen von
wohnungen die schon genehmigt sind die
darauf warten gebaut zu werden und wir
müssen alles tun um die art und weise
wie wir bauen effizienter zu gestalten
damit diese wohnungen dann tatsächlich
auch schnell gebaut werden können dabei
ist ein wichtiger punkt die
transformation wir müssen die
produktivität der bauwirtschaft erhöhen
neben bagger und zement müssen in
zukunft auch software und künstliche
intelligenz ihren platz am bau haben und
wir investieren 10 millionen in böhmen
und wir werden sämtliche
verwaltungsprozesse im baubereich
digitalisieren das fängt an beim
raumordnungsgesetz den digitalen
planungsverfahren geht über die
einführung der digitalen bauakte bis zur
einführung von digitalen gebäude
zwilling wir haben
angekündigt
dass der bundeskanzler im herbst mit den
ländern einen pakt zur planungs und
genehmigungsbeschluss schließen wird und
weinbauminister haben wird wesentlichen
beitrag dazu leisten dass vor ort
schneller geplant werden kann dass die
kommunen so ausgestattet sind dass die
verfahren so modernisiert werden dass
das passieren kann ein zweiter punkt ist
der wichtige punkt klimaschutz bedürfen
klimaschutz und wohnungsneubau nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen sondern wir
müssen sehen wie wir mit nachhaltigen
baustoffen wie wir mit modernen bauform
ist schaffen beides miteinander zusammen
zu bringen und wir investieren in den
zusammenhalt unserer gesellschaft die
476 millionen euro die wir zur verfügung
haben in diesem jahr um schwimmbäder um
sporthallen um bolzplätze energetisch zu
sanieren
das ist eine große unterstützung für den
sport für die zivilgesellschaft für die
kommunen und für alle menschen die sich
begegnen wollen
die städtebauförderung ist etabliert sie
wird auf hohem niveau von 790 millionen
euro fortgeführt und sie haben es
erwähnt ja wohl auch das programm
nationale projekte des städtebaus dass
den abgeordneten des bundestages ganz
besonders am herzen liegt wird mit 75
mio weitergeführt und wir werden es auch
dieses jahr schaffen die wichtigen
projekte in diesem bereich auszuführen
und zwei punkte sind mir ganz wichtig
das eine ist die frage
barrierefreier umbau von wohngebäuden
das wird ein schwerpunkt sein auch in
den beratungen des bündnisses für
bezahlbares bauen es ist doch kein
zufall dass ich gesagt habe ich will
dass der beauftragte der bundesregierung
für die belange von menschen mit
behinderung mitglied im bündnis ist dass
wir den agenten mitglied im bündnis ist
weil wir natürlich
einen sehr sehr großen bedarf haben und
wir haben eine sehr zersplitterten
förderlandschaft wir haben das
kfw-darlehen wir haben die kfw
unterstützung jetzt über diesen haushalt
wir haben einzelne landesprogramme und
ich bin der meinung dass wir diese
mittel auch bündeln müssen um es den
betroffenen so einfach zurück wie
möglich zu machen und ihnen auch die
sicherheit zu geben dass wenn sie ihre
wohnung umgebaut haben dass sie dieser
nicht beim auszug auch wieder
zurückbauen müssen das ja vollkommen
unsinnig der zweite punkt die anpassung
der urbanen räume an den klimawandel
auch hier fließen 176 millionen euro
über den etf in die förderung unserer
städte wir merken es die sommer die
werden heißer sie werden trockner und
die städte das grün in den städten ist
unter stress und wir brauchen auch mehr
speichern sich keitel für wasser bei
starkregen ereignisse muss es schnell
abfließen können und im sommer muss es
dazu beitragen unsere städte zu kühlen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
transformation ist das stichwort der
heutigen zeit und mit diesem haushalt
beginnen wir auch in der politik eine
neue phase es geht um eine
zukunftsaufgabe nämlich darum die wir
genug bezahlbaren klimagerechten
wohnraum schaffen wir ein innovatives
bauwesen in deutschland schaffen wie wir
es schaffen können schwung für die
digitalisierung im gebäudebereich und im
quartier zu schaffen und wie wir gerade
nach bewohner dazu beitragen dass unsere
stadtquartiere und ortskerne lebendig
bleiben oder werden und wir brauchen
eine besondere achtsamkeit für die
älteren und schwächeren in unserer
gesellschaft und ich weiß die kommunen
sind oder starkem stress was diese
ganzen transformationen angelangt die
verkehrswende die bau wende die klima
anpassungsmaßnahmen unser ministerium
wird ihnen an ihrer seite stehen der
haushalt den sie beraten haben die
einzelplan 25 denen sie aufgepäppelt
haben der ist auch für eine großartige
grundlage herzlichen dank
klara geywitz ministerin für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen mit einem
überblick zu den projekten ihres hauses
ihres ministeriums ein punkt natürlich
in diesen zeiten das klimagerechtes
bauen
aber sie wird gemessen werden an den
vorgaben die die bundesregierung selber
gemacht hat 400.000 neue wohnungen pro
jahr davon 100.000 sozial gebunden marc
bernhard ist am pult für die afd und er
ist sprecher für bauen und wohnen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
frau ministerin geiwitz sie wollen die
co2 emissionen von gebäuden bis 20.30
halbieren in gerade mal acht jahren
gleichzeitig haben sie auch gerade eben
gesagt wollen sie bauen
sozialverträglich gestalten beides
zusammen ist schlichtweg unmöglich und
viele menschen werden bei ihren plänen
auf der strecke bleiben die hälfte der
mieter in deutschen großstädten müssen
heute schon mehr als 30 prozent vom
netto für die miete beraten 26 prozent
zahlen über 40 und 12 prozent sogar über
50 fürs wohnen dabei mussten bereits
2020 über 7,4 millionen menschen frieren
weil sie nicht genug geld fürs heizen
hatten wie viele menschen sollen unter
ihrer regierung denn eigentlich noch
dazukommen ihre klimaziele im baubereich
umzusetzen würde nichts anderes bedeuten
als millionen von intakten wohnungen
abzureißen weil dies auch mit der
teuersten sanierung gar nicht ihrem
geplanten
standard er 55 überhaupt erreichen
könnten und bei diesem standard kostet
ein quadratmeter heute schon
3400 euro und das führt zu einer
kaltmiete von mindestens 13 euro 50 und
das können sich heute schon 80 prozent
der menschen gar nicht mehr leisten und
ab 2025 wollen sie ja sogar 40 zum
standard machen und das wird dann
endgültig zu unbezahlbar kite führen das
haben wir auch im übrigen heute morgen
in der anhörung gehört für das fehlen
von 2.000.000 bezahlbaren wohnungen
machen sie lieferengpässe
rohstoffknappheit und preissteigerungen
verantwortlich kommen aber nicht auf die
idee
dass ihre gesetze verordnungen steuern
und abgaben des bauen extrem verteuern
und in immer neue höhen treiben also
frau ministerin sie können sich entweder
an ihren völlig unrealistischen plänen
festhalten die menschen frieren lassen
und wohnen zum luxus machen oder endlich
für bezahlbare warme wohnungen sorgen
aber was machen sie was machen sie in
diesem haushalt
luxusprojekte fördern beispielsweise
eine kita im kanzleramt kosten 28
millionen euro für sage und schreibe
zwölf bis 15 kinder für das gleiche geld
werden sonst überall im land kitas für
80 kinder gebaut damit kosten diese
luxus kita-plätze fünfmal so viel wie
für die normalen menschen da draußen
geldverschwendung ist auch ihr programm
be back sie fordern damit zum beispiel
koch videos der volkshochschule coburg
in denen gezeigt wird wie man pfannen
brötchen backt oder
in nürnberg ein videoprojekt erwerbs
integration das in eineinhalb jahren
sage und schreibe ganze 16 mal
aufgerufen wurde
welch ein irrwitz frau gallwitz an
diesem beispiel sieht man wo die
prioritäten dieser regierung lieben
frau ministerin ihre erste und
wichtigste aufgabe muss es doch sein für
ausreichend bezahlbare und warme
wohnungen zu sorgen und nicht das geld
der bürger für luxusprojekte oder
nonsens programme wie biwak auszugeben
damit wohnen in deutschland endlich
wieder für jeden bezahlbar wird fordern
wir die senkung der grunderwerbsteuer
die abschaffung der grundsteuer und die
streichung aller
kostentreibenden bauvorschriften
und frau ministerin ich bitte sie fanden
brötchen backen gehört wirklich nicht zu
den aufgaben ihres ministeriums
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun der kollege andreas andric das
wort
entschuldigung aber das ist hier nicht
zu entziffern gewesen
dennoch sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren wohnen ist
ein grundbedürfnis und wohnen ist auch
ein grundrecht wohnraum darf kein
luxusgut sein und in vielen städten in
deutschland sehen wir leider dass es
dennoch genauso ist manche menschen
stehen
stundenlang an an wohnungen immer in der
angst keine zu bekommen immer in der
angst die wohnung die sie brauchen nicht
zu bekommen oder aus der alten wohnung
rauszufliegen sich für ein iphone
anzustellen oder für andere luxusgüter
dass es in ordnung bei wohnungen dürfen
wir das niemals akzeptieren
bundes eine der ganz großen sozialen
fragen unserer zeit und von wohnungen
hängt so viel ab und deswegen es ist
richtig dass diese bundesregierung ein
neues ministerium geschaffen hat diese
koalition ein neues ministerium
geschaffen hat dass sich diesen
herausforderungen ganz speziell widmet
und dafür einen eigenen etat zur
verfügung hat die ministerin hat das
eingehend ausgeführt und das ist auch
richtig dass wir in diesem etat einen
ganz großen teil des geldes für den
sozialen wohnungsbau ausgeben bis 2026
14,5 milliarden euro das ist mehr als
das dreifache
die ursprünglich in der finanzplanung
vorgesehen war und das ist gut so und
das ist richtig so
denn wohnraum zu schaffen wohnraum zu
schaffen ist auch eine staatliche
aufgabe es rächt sich jetzt und wir
sehen jetzt wie es sich recht dass der
staat sich in den letzten jahren immer
mehr aus der wohnungspolitik
zurückgezogen hatte der schwund an
sozialwohnungen ist ein ernstzunehmendes
problem überall in deutschland und wir
werden das mit der politik die wir jetzt
von seiten der arm machen aufhalten und
zurückdrängen wir schaffen einen zweiten
einen doppelten boden auf dem
wohnungsmarkt und weil wir eine echte
wende wollen und weil wir sozialen
wohnungsbau auch klima gerecht machen
wollen geben wir natürlich auch geld für
das klimagerechte wohnen und bauen aus
und verbinden so dass soziale und die
klimafrage in der politik bei uns
hunderttausend sozialwohnungen jährlich
das ist eine menge holz aber wir wissen
dass das am ende nicht ausreichend wird
und deswegen freue ich mich so dass wir
mit dem haushalt
2022 auch endlich das kfw programm zur
förderung von genossenschaftsanteilen
staaten konnten millionen menschen in
deutschland schließen sich zusammen sie
planen gemeinsam sie schaffen wohnraum
gemeinsam aber sie schaffen noch viel
mehr sie schaffen dauerhaft günstigen
wohnraum stellen den zur verfügung und
probieren gleichzeitig ganz viele neue
wohnformen aus sie übernehmen
verantwortung füreinander weit über die
kernfamilie hinaus und das ist an der
stelle nicht nur der start eines
weiteren
kfw-programms dass es gleichzeitig auch
das zeichen dieser koalition dass
genossenschaften die eigenheime der
zukunft sind und dafür gleichermaßen die
verantwortungsübernahme für einander in
dieser gesellschaft fördern
das geschafft ist ein erster schritt wir
wollen aber weiter wir wollen auch im
haushalt 2023 weiterkommen und daran
anknüpfen die neue wohngebiet wohnen
gemeinnützigkeit steht im
koalitionsvertrag und muss kommen denn
sie schafft dauerhaft
günstigen wohnraum und alle die bereit
sind in der gesellschaft verantwortung
zu übernehmen sollen dann auch
profitieren können genau darum geht es
es geht nicht um start auf der einen
seite und privat auf der anderen seite
oder ein gegeneinander dieser beiden
dieser beiden richtungen sondern es geht
um die frage wer bereit ist in der
gesellschaft verantwortung zu übernehmen
und sich an kriterien zu halten und
soziales und ökologisches wohnen auf den
weg zu bringen das ist die maxime der
politik und deswegen werden wir die wohn
gemeinnützigkeit mit den nächsten jahren
einführen
zu hause muss sicherheit bieten und ein
zuhause muss geborgenheit bieten beides
geht verloren wenn heizkosten
explodieren und menschen sich nicht mehr
sicher sein können ob sie das
finanzieren können mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss haben wir deswegen
hier kurzfristig für abhilfe gesorgt 270
euro die direkt bei denen ankommen die
diese unterstützung auch tatsächlich
brauchen das ist gut und gleichzeitig
ist klar dass wir lösungen auch für den
nächsten winter finden müssen wir
erleben dass gaspreise ein zentraler
treiber der inflation sind dass die
gaspreise gleichzeitig von diktator
wladimir putin dazu genutzt werden um
sie als kriegswaffe auch einzusetzen und
um gesellschaften zu spalten und mit
blick auf dem nächsten auf den nächsten
winter steht deswegen für uns auch im
mittelpunkt niemand in deutschland darf
in einer kalten wohnung sitzen jede und
jeder hier in deutschland hat ein recht
auf ein warmes zuhause und das werden
wir gemeinsam erfüllen
wohnungen der zukunft müssen mehr
leisten wohnungen der zukunft müssen so
gebaut oder saniert sein dass sie für
alle zugänglich sind auch für menschen
mit behinderung auch für ältere menschen
und so schwer die situation auf dem
wohnungsmarkt für ganz ganz viele
menschen ist desto mehr wissen wir wie
schwer es ist wenn menschen zum beispiel
im rollstuhl sitzen und eine wohnung
suchen der anteil an barrierearmen oder
barrierefreien wohnungen ist immer noch
viel zu klein und deswegen haben wir
hier im bundestag in den beratungen
gesagt dass wir das programm
altersgerecht umbauen nicht auslaufen
lassen wollen sondern dass wir wollen
dass dieses programm weitergeführt wird
und haben dafür ganz dezidiert mittel
eingestellt
weil täter nicht nur um das sanieren von
wohnungen in einer alternden
gesellschaft und in einer gesellschaft
oder demografische wandel so eine große
rolle spielt ist die frage ob es
finanzierbar ist ob man das badezimmer
umbauen kann eine frage von
selbstbestimmtheit und auch eine frage
von freiheit und insofern investieren
wir gerade in einer alternden
gesellschaft hier auch in freiheit und
selbstbestimmung von menschen
die wohnung ist das eine darüber habe
ich viel gesprochen wie wir an der
stelle politik machen aber das
wohnumfeld ist das zweite und auch das
ist adressiert in diesem etat wir wollen
die ganzen potenziale unserer
innenstädte und ortskerne heben und
haben genau das mit geld in dem etat
hinterlegt darum haben wir auch wiederum
hier im bundestag in den
haushaltsberatungen mittel
bereitgestellt um das programm nationale
projekte des städtebaus fortzuführen
weil es uns ein anliegen war genau das
hier voran zu bringen und wir müssen
jeden euro so investieren dass wir
künftig auf nachhaltigkeit setzen und
die uns so auch auf die zukunft
vorbereiten und dafür wappnen deswegen
wird das programm zur sanierung
kommunaler einrichtungen ab jetzt auch
zur energetischen sanierung genutzt es
ist nur konsequent dass wir das programm
künftig aus dem klima- und
transformations- fonds finanzieren denn
wir bekämpfen klimakrise künftig auch
beim umbau von sportstätten oder auch
bei gebäuden in der jugend und
kulturarbeit
wir haben die beratungen genutzt um den
entwurf der bundesregierung hier im
bundestag besser zu machen und wir
bereiten uns damit auch vor auf die
nächsten jahre werden daran anknüpfen
und gemeinsam auch dann die wende
herbeiführen und das ganze sozial und
ökologisch nachhaltig gestalten danken
für die fraktion die linke hat nun die
kollegin karen leidet
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren die bundesregierung
bauch vor allen dingen eines
luftschlösser
beginnen wir mit den angekündigten
400.000 wohnungen pro jahr nur etwa
290.000 wurden im letzten jahr fertig
gestellte sind 4,2 weniger als vor einem
jahr sie scheitern an den eigenen selbst
gesteckten ziele
dabei waren sie es die in bauen bauen
bauen das allheilmittel für den
wohnungsmarkt für die wohnungskrise
gesehen haben wie er pflege haben immer
gesagt es kommt darauf an was gebaut
wird aber gerade beim sozialen
wohnungsbau können sie uns nicht sagen
wie die versprochenen 100.000
sozialwohnungen pro jahr finanziert war
ich habe die bundesregierung gefragt
welche berechnung der hinterlegt antwort
es gibt keine berechnungen sie
versprechen 100.000 sozialwohnung jahr
und können nicht sagen dieses
finanzieren wollen das ist ja wohl
absurd
und da es keine kalkulationen geliefert
wird können wir gemeinsam überschlagen
14,5 milliarden euro sollen ausgegeben
haben also eine verdreifachung der
mittel ungefähr das ist gut gerade weil
ich an dieser stelle sehr lange auch
vergeblich für eine erhöhung der mittel
für den sozialen wohnungsbau gekämpft
habe aber mit einer verdreifachung der
mittel mehr teile für vier fassungen der
sozialwohnungen zu finanzieren bei
gestiegenen kosten also entschuldigung
dass es einfach wunschdenken
wobei markus lässt sich die ministerin
in die karten der magischen rechnung
schauen und sie darf die länder sollen
mehr finanzieren sie seien ja eigentlich
zuständig aber ich will daran erinnern
wir haben hier gemeinsam das grundgesetz
geändert gerade weil der bund wieder in
die verantwortung für den sozialen
wohnungsbau gehen sollte schon alleine
deswegen können wir ihnen nicht
durchgehen lassen die schuld bei den
ländern abzuladen das lassen wir ihnen
nicht durchgehen
das ziel hunderttausend sozialwohnungen
zu bauen das ist richtig aber stellen
sie das geld bereit staates und brüstung
zu versenken
meine anfrage bundes sein denn
immobilien anstalt beamer brachten auch
wenig rühmliches zutage die bima hatte
im letzten jahr sage und schreibe sechs
wohnungen gebaut sie lassen wohnungen in
größenordnungen leer stehen das ist
einfach nur peinlich
die neuen buches gemeinnützigkeit muss
kommen ja genau das sehen wir jetzt
linke genauso aber wo ist sie denn ich
meine es geht auch darum eine nicht
profitorientierte sektor auf dem
wohnungsmarkt aufzubauen das muss so
schnell wie möglich kommen das muss
möglich sein das darf nicht länger auf
sich warten und deswegen müsste vom
ersten tag an jeder euro den wir
ausgeben im bau haushalt in den aufbau
dieser neuen boden gemeinnützigkeit
fließen anstatt weiter
wohnungskonzern mit millionenbeträgen zu
subventionieren die am ende dann das
geld als dividende an die aktionäre
ausschütten das ist absurd ihnen solche
der vorderhand zugedreht werden
wir müssen doch wie wertig städte und
gemeinden unterstützen dass sie mehr
bauen bauen wie in wien das ist unsere
lösung kaufen wir uns die stadt zurück
das ist unsere losung
wir uns denke ist klar wohnen muss
bezahlbar sein wir wollen mehr als 20
milliarden euro jährlich mehr
investieren 15 milliarden im jahr für
sozialen kommunalen und gemeinnützigen
wohnungsbau und teil des programms muss
eben auch ein ankaufprogramm seien für
sozialwohnungen für belegungsrechte für
rekommunalisierung damit sich auch
menschen mit kleinem geldbeutel endlich
wieder eine wohnung leisten können
wir brauchen den bogen zum haben mit
baumann wieder bezahlbar wird und
klimagerechtes sanierungsprogramm in
höhe von 5 milliarden euro im jahr den
klimaschutz muss auch ohne mieterhöhung
möglich sein
von chris kg hatte in berlin einen
unausgegoren und forscher präsentiert
nicht mehr jeder soll nicht mehr als 30
prozent des einkommens für das wohnen
ausgeben das ist richtig aber als
allgemeine forderung ist es wenig
handhabbar wir haben einen vorschlag
gemacht beim wohngeld konnte man das
konkret mit diesem haushalt beschließen
das ist unser vorschlag als linke und
zu guter letzt es hat natürlich nicht
alles mit geld zu tun man könnte auch
einfach gute gesetze machen wir
bräuchten einen bundesweiten mieten
deckel oder wenigstens fünf jahre
mädchens doch und das halten die spd
habe noch vollmundig versprochen aber
jetzt ist doch nichts davon übrigen
koalitionsvertrag kein wörter für noch
nichtmals das vorkaufsrecht kriegen sie
ja geändert obwohl es sich um einen
einzigen paragrafen handelt also in der
letzten legislatur hieß es immer die spd
kann sich als kleiner koalitionspartner
nicht gegen die cdu durchsetzen jetzt
stellt sie den kanzler sie stellen die
ministerin sie haben mit den grünen
zusammen eine mehrheit in dieser
koalition sich nicht gegen die fdp
durchsetzen also sonne genossen da
stimmt was nicht
also fasst sich ein herz setzen sie auf
wahlversprechen durch das monopoly muss
beendet werden
carla bley vergleicht die
wohnungspolitik mit einem monopoly spiel
jedenfalls am ende ihrer rede karten da
ist ja sprecherin für mieten bau und
wohnungspolitik hier geht es weiter um
den etat des bundesbauministeriums
unterstrich etwas mehr herbst aus der
fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir diskutieren heute
über einen besonderen einzelplan
besonders aber der einzelplan eines
neuen ministeriums ist und besonders
auch weil wir hier im bereich das
bauministerium die höchste
investitionsquote in allen
haushaltsplänen haben und das ist halt
positiv auf die investitionsquote des
bundeshaushaltes ein wichtiges unserer
sicht nur durch mich nur kommt
konsumieren wir müssen investieren und
das tun wir mit diesem haushalt
die aufgaben im bereich des
bauministeriums sind zweifellos groß es
geht darum wohnen bezahlbar zu gestalten
bauinvestitionen zu unterstützen bremsen
zu lösen es geht darum eignet ums
bildung zu ermöglichen
und es geht darum die stadtentwicklung
weiter voranzutreiben das ist vor dem
aktuellen umfeld alles nicht trivial das
ist völlig klar aber wir sind als
koalition entschlossen diese
herausforderung anzugehen ich bin
überzeugt dass neue bauministerium wird
mit uns gemeinsam in dieser koalition
die richtigen akzente setzen
ein haushalt von rund fünf milliarden
das klingt auf den ersten blick recht
viel das klingt nach viel
gestaltungsspielraum aber zur wahrheit
gehört auch dass das vorgänger
ministerium was csu geführt war unser
viele verpflichtungen hinterlassen hat
programme die wir jetzt finanzieren
müssen und die unseren
gestaltungsspielräumen einengen dennoch
konnten wir neue akzente setzen ich
möchte zwei hier erwähnen das programm
altersgerecht umbauen es bekommt jetzt
frisches geld weil wir älteren menschen
ermöglichen wollen länger in den eigenen
vier wänden zu leben das ist
selbstbestimmtes leben und es ist nicht
nur eine wohnungspolitische sondern auch
eine soziale frage meine damen und
herren
und wir könnten zudem neue bundesmittel
für kommunale investitionsprojekte
mobilisieren ich stehe jetzt 400
millionen euro zur verfügung für die
sanierung von sport kultur
freizeiteinrichtungen wer die situation
kennt wir alles sehen dass in unseren
wahlkreisen dass es dringend benötigtes
geld das ist gut angelegtes geld
die zwischenrufe aus der csu natürlich
gab es die forschern aber wenn wir nicht
frisches geld investieren würden ja kein
euro verfügbar um mit neue projekte
anzugehen
und meine damen und herren ich freue
mich auch dass es gelungen ist dass wir
jetzt einen anstoß geben ein neues
programm zur förderung von privaten
wohneigentums
vorzulegen bis oktober über das
förderkonzept gearbeitet und ich sage
immer mehr sozialer wohnungsbau und mehr
privates wohneigentum das sind keine
gegensätze wir brauchen beides in
unserem land
und übrigens beide bereiche haben ja die
gleichen herausforderung wir sehen
steigende baukosten engpässe bei
fachkräften bei baumaterial
aufsteigender bau zins und es deshalb
eine herausforderung war ja wohl nicht
irgendein luxus ist wohnen ist ein
existenzielles bedürfnis und nicht nur
wohnen sondern auch das wohneigentum ist
ein existenzielles bedürfnissen wir
sehen ist ja als aufgabe an einer
gesellschaft dass wir das
aufstiegsversprechen auch damit umsetzen
dass jemand der hart arbeitet sie etwas
zurück legt dass der sich privates
wohneigentum leisten kann der traum vom
wohneigentum darf nicht zum
unerreichbaren ziele werden in
diesem zusammenhang anders als die linke
das darstellt es sind ja nicht alle
vermieter diese gierigen großen konzerne
die vermeintlich gierig sinn über über
60 prozent aller vermieteten wohnung in
diesem land gehören kleinen kleinst
vermieden die haben manchmal eine
manchmal zwei wohnungen und ohne die an
engagement es auf dem wohnungsmarkt in
deutschland ganz anders aus
die fachkräftesituation im baubereich
die bleibt anstrengend und das baustoff
thema mit sicherheit auch deshalb geht
es auch darum dass ihre produktivität
und innovation fördern denn wir kommen
nur aus dem dilemma heraus wenn wir
effizienter bauen und ich dich wurde
sind digitalisierung series bauen
baustoff forschung nur durch innovation
machen wir das bauen effiziente und wir
müssen effizienter machen
wenn wir sehen ja auch die teure wir
bauen desto teurer werden natürlich die
mieten und deshalb müssen wir alles
dafür tun dass die kosten nicht
unendlich steigen wenn schon am markt
die kosten deutlich steigen dann darf
das starten und nach dem kostentreiber
werden das ist unsere gemeinsame
verantwortung hier in diesem haus
als koalition wollen wir die
voraussetzung geschaffen dass wieder
mehr gebaut werden kann daß
genehmigungen vereinfacht werden dass
der boden raum bezahlbar bleibt dass
sich mehr menschen den traum vom
wohneigentum erfüllen können dass es
unser anspruch den wir als koalition
haben und bedanke mich ausdrücklich bei
man mit berichterstattern in der
koalition ich bedanke mich beim
bauministerium die großes geleistet habe
bei der haushaltsaufstellung trotz eines
ministeriums was sich im aufbau befindet
und ich bedanke mich auch bei den
berichterstattenden koalition es waren
insgesamt sehr konstruktive sehr faire
verhandlungen meine damen und herren wir
haben jetzt erste weichen für eine
moderne innovative politik gestellt
weitere werden mit dem haushalt 2023
folgen vielen dank
torsten herbst für die fdp-fraktion und
beim thema wohnen zum thema wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen jetzt
erzählen da aus der unionsfraktion und
präzise zu sein aus der csu landesgruppe
in diesem haushalt ist gar nichts von
innovationen zu spüren und zu lesen und
zu sehen keine real labore für
nachhaltiges bauen kein ki cluster bau
keine digitalisierung als im nachhinein
wurde da entsprechend nachgesteuert das
können wir als union so nicht stehen
lassen dass sie angeblich die
fortschritts koalition sind im bau
haushalt ist davon nichts zu sehen
wir als union haben uns gefreut dass ein
neues bauministerium entstehen sollte
wir waren neugierig auf die umsetzung da
es dem wichtigen thema wohnen mehr
gewicht verleiht dafür können die
menschen in unserem land aber auch zu
recht etwas erwarten nämlich dass
politik dann auch liefert dieses
ministerium muss den unterschied machen
aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt müsste das
bauministerium er zum baustopp
ministerium umbenannt werden ein
mehrwert ist nicht erkennbar
zukunftsträchtige konzepte fehlanzeige
die fährte fertigstellen neuer wohnungen
geht im vergleich zum letzten jahr die
korrekt kollegin mey hat angesprochen
sogar zurück das ziel der
bundesregierung
400.000 neue wohnungen zu bauen rückt in
weite ferne dafür können sich die ampel
regierung als personalaufbau koalition
aber 10.000 neue stellen das ist sicher
aber ob die ampel in der lage ist in
gleicher geschwindigkeit 10.000 neue
wohnungen zu organisieren das wage ich
zu bezweifeln
die spd hat sich einfach schon zu beginn
der ampelkoalition verzockt viel zu spät
haben sie ihre ministerin berufen die
bundesanstalt für immobilienaufgaben
ging an das finanzministerium und die
themen kfw-förderung und energetische
sanierung von gebäuden liegt beim
wirtschaftsministerium da ist es auch
nur folgerichtig dass diese beiden
schlüssel ministerium ministerien fürs
bauen erst gar nicht zum von ministerin
geiwitz initiierten bündnis bezahlbarer
wohnraum eingeladen waren dabei muss man
sich schon die frage stellen ob die
bauministerin und der
wirtschaftsminister bank beim bauen
überhaupt an einem strang ziehen die
eine will kosten günstig bauen der
andere schraubt die anforderungen zur
energetischen gebäudesanierung hoch und
im ergebnis verursacht man einen
zweimaligen kfw förderstopp und lässt
damit familien städte und gemeinden und
alle bauwilligen im stich die ja
durchaus für nachhaltiges bauen offen
sind dabei sind die
grundvoraussetzungen für investitionen
in wohnraum egal ob in kommunale im
privater gemeinnütziger verantwortung
immer an verlässlichkeit und
berechenbarkeit
gekoppelt denn alle müssen egal in
welchen haushalten verlässlich
kalkulieren können
und da frage ich mich schon wo sind die
glaubhaften konzepte zur
klimaneutralität bei der
gebäudesanierung in denen sie
beschreiben wie diese finanziert und
diese b realisiert werden sollen wo ist
die steuerliche abschreibung liebe
kollegen von der fdp wo dem die erhöht
werden soll von zwei auf drei prozent wo
ist die auskömmliche finanzierung für
den altersgerechten umbau der immens
wichtig ist in einer der ältesten
gesellschaft dieser welt wo sind die
konzepte zur eigentumsförderung überall
nur dienst nach vorschrift oder sie sind
komplett blank das baukindergeld
beispielsweise
wenn sie natürlich schlecht finden wenn
sie meinen das ist der ansatz fakt ist
aber gerade das schwellen haushalte
davon massiv profitiert haben auch
die soziale wohnraumförderung wird wie
schon in der letzten regierung
vorgesehen aufgestockt aber auch das ist
nicht auskömmlich um ihr selbst
gestecktes ziel von 100.000 neuen
sozialwohnungen erreichen zu können
sogar an die städtebaumittel wollten sie
ran und dankenswerterweise haben es die
kollegen in den haushalts bereinigungen
noch verhindert hindern können dieser
haushalt ist wenig zukunftsweisend aber
gerade hier gilt auch das vertrauen in
der politik die summe der gehaltenen
versprechen ist und daran werden wir sie
auf messen vielen dank
mit seiner war das aus der
unionsfraktion in dieser debatte über
den etat des bundesministeriums und
jetzt ist uwe schmidt am rednerpult aus
der spd-fraktion einer der wenigen
handwerker kfz-mechaniker und hafen
facharbeiter hat er mal gelernt
das herzstück ihrer politik ist die
schaffung von bezahlbarem wohnraum als
nationale aufgabe habe ich eben ihrer
rede entnommen der bund unterstützt die
länder dabei mit erheblichen mitteln
waren auch die länder sind dafür
zuständig wohnungen zu bauen insgesamt
14,5 milliarden euro sind für den
sozialen und klimagerechten wohnungsbau
bis 20 26 in diesem haushalt eingeplant
unmittelbar nach inkrafttreten dieses
bundeshaushalt ist können die länder
bereits über zwei milliarden euro
verfügen und die länder liegen
ihrerseits mindestens noch 30 prozent
der bundesmittel obendrauf denn wird im
parlamentarischen verfahren aber den
haushaltsentwurf noch besser gemacht
damit zusätzlichen mitteln zielgerecht
verstärkt einige punkte möchte ich dabei
noch mal heraus greifen die wesentlichen
ziele im koalitionsvertrag an meine
beiden vorrednern außerhalb der schon
genannte wohneigentum darf kein luxus
für besserverdienende sein wir stellen
daher 6 millionen euro zum erwerb von
genossenschaftsanteilen für selbst
genutzten wohnraum zur verfügung
damit ermöglichen wir es künftig jungen
familien mit durchschnittlichen
einkommen wohneigentum zu erwerben
die ampel hat jung und alt gleichermaßen
im blick wir standen das kfw programm
zum altersgerechten umbau von
wohngebäuden mit zusätzlich 75 millionen
euro ja das reicht immer nicht bei denen
es ist viel zu wenig mit den mitteln
fördern wir den barrierearmen umbau von
wohnungen außenbereichen so ermöglichen
wir einen höheren wohnkomfort im alter
in unserer immer älter werdenden
bevölkerung ist dies auch dringend
notwendig hat die ministerin eben auch
schon angedeutet auch der städtebau
steht vor großen herausforderungen steht
gewachsen immer schneller wohnraum wird
immer knapper und die luft in den
großstädten immer schlechter auch die
stadt entwicklungen muss auf den
klimawandel reagieren um weitere
vorbilder für projekte der nachhaltigen
stadtentwicklung und des städtebaus in
ganz deutschland zu schaffen haben wir
die mittel für die nationalen projekte
des städtebaus um weitere 75 millionen
euro erhöht
unsere städte und kommunen reagieren auf
die vielfältigen städtebaulichen
herausforderungen mit innovativen
konzepten wie das gewächshaus auf dem
dach die vernetzung von kunst und
grünflächen im quartier oder andere
städtebauliche innovation zur lösung
drängender zukunftsaufgaben die städte
dazu kommen sind nachhaltig klimaneutral
grün und vernetzt in diesem haushalt
haben wir noch zwei weitere programme
für die stadtentwicklung im
bauministerium
die dort bewirtschaftet werden
implantiert in den beratungen es ist uns
gelungen das erfolgreiche programm
sanierung kommunaler einrichtungen in
sport jugend und kultur neu aufzulegen
insgesamt 476 millionen euro stehen in
den nächsten jahren für neue projekte
bereit
wir unterstützen damit die städte und
gemeinden bei zahlreichen
sanierungsprojekten und erhalten damit
wichtige soziale infrastruktur vor ort
ob der sportverein um die ecke der
jugendclub in der nachbarschaft oder die
kulturstätten sie alle leisten
tagtäglich einen großartigen beitrag für
den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
zusammenhalt und die soziale integration
in unserem land aspekte des
klimaschutzes werden künftig auch hier
eine größere rolle bei den
förderkriterien spielen so denken wir
klimaschutz und sanierungen zusammen und
sorgen für sicherheit im wandel für das
sonderprogramm anpassung urbaner räume
an den klimawandel haben wir die mittel
ebenfalls um 176 millionen euro erhöht
insgesamt stehen 375 millionen euro
bereit damit die kommunen öffentliche
parks und gärten klimafreundlich
weiterentwickeln können städtisches grün
trägt erheblich zur reduktion der
treibhausgasemissionen bei kommunen wird
so ein aktiver beitrag zum klimaschutz
ermöglicht all das in zukunft
investitionen in das bezahlbare wohnen
die nachhaltige stadtentwicklung und das
klimafreundliche baum mein dank geht an
unsere bundesministerin klara geywitz
vielen dank an meine kollegen andreas
auth rich und torsten herbst das war
eine produktive zusammenarbeit mit sehr
guten ergebnissen und schließlich gilt
mein dank den vielen mitarbeitenden im
hintergrund in den abgeordnetenbüros
einen recht schönen dank
das wort hat der abgeordnete markus oehl
wie die afg 14
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
bezahlbares wohnen ist eine der großen
sozialen fragen in dieser zeit inflation
astronomische energiepreise und grüne
auflagen und verbote für haus bauwillige
ziehen unseren bürgern das geld aus der
tasche hinzu kommen die
wohnungsknappheit vor allem in
ballungsräumen die unter anderem durch
die völlig gescheiterten
migrationspolitik entstanden ist und
diese politik wird mit der neuen
regierung noch viel schlimmer bauen ist
in deutschland so teuer wie nie die
preise für baumaterial sind enorm hoch
und durch lieferengpässe ist material
knapp das stellt gerade handwerks und
baubetriebe bei der abgabe von angeboten
vor enorme herausforderungen
ob ihr angebot im laufe des
baufortschritts überhaupt haltbar sein
wird nicht wenige betriebe bringt das in
existenzielle nöte durch die
materialknappheit können vielerorts die
bauzeiten nicht eingehalten werden das
wird in diesem jahr zu einer stagnation
im baugewerbe führen das betrifft nicht
nur die zielerreichung der versprochenen
400.000 wohnungen sondern es betrifft
auch viele familien die sich selbst
gerne ihre eigenen vier wände schaffen
wollen die hohen preise führen dazu dass
die baukosten für diese familien massiv
steigen und damit deren finanzen ins
wanken geraten wir befinden uns in
schweren zeiten es braucht hilfe hilfe
vor allem durch die politik was die
dämpfung von materialpreisen angeht
hilfe aber auch von einer politik die
regeln vereinfacht und diese nicht
weiter verschärft unter dem deckmantel
klimaneutral wird die kostenspirale
durch die links gelbe koalition weiter
hochgetrieben das kann sich unser land
jedoch nicht leisten
sie würden mit ihren verboten auflagen
privates bauen grössenordnungen ab weil
es dadurch kaum oder gar nicht mehr
finanzierbar wird frau ministerin ihr
haus steht vor großen aufgaben mit der
einhaltung des gegebenen versprechens
jährlich 400.000 wohnungen bauen zu
wollen um mit dem im ergänzungs haushalt
vorgesehen einmaligen zuschuss für
heizkosten zum wohngeld dieses jahr wird
es nicht getan sein dieser einmalige
zuschuss ist nur ein tropfen auf dem
heißen stein
hier sind sie und ihre kollegen zum
handeln aufgefordert damit sich viele
bürger im kommenden winter nicht die
frage stellen müssen ob sie entweder
heizen oder etwas zu essen kaufen wir
werden diesem haushalt in dieser form
daher nicht zustimmen ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
marcus böhme war das aus der fdp
fraktion betont materialknappheit hohe
baukosten verbote und auflagen die das
bei uns schwer machen würde personal und
fachkräftemangel erwähnt er nicht anja
liebert ist die nächste rednerin kommt
aus der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
und ist mitglied im ausschuss für wohnen
stadtentwicklung
bauwesen und kommunen frau präsidentin
werte kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren die bundesregierung hat
in den sechs monaten in denen sie die
verantwortung trägt die weichen in der
bau und wohnungspolitik
definitiv neu gestellt und das zentrale
anliegen des hier verhandelten einzel
plant ist die schaffung von zusätzlichem
wohnraum und für uns grüne geht es dabei
darum dass soziale und ökologische
miteinander in einklang zu bringen
und ganz konkret machen wir das ja auch
schon mit der klima milliarde die jetzt
im haushalt
2022 zu finden ist wir fördern
energetisch hochwertigen neubau die
finanzplanung sieht die 14 5 milliarden
euro für den sozialen wohnungsbau vor
und mit dieser sozial gerechten und
ökologischen bau und wohnungspolitik
wollen wir dafür sorgen dass alle
menschen in sicheren bezahlbaren und
klimagerechten wohnungen leben können
und was die cdu und hinterlassen hat
nämlich das thema auslaufende
fördermittel um was herr altmaier vorher
da eben nicht zu ende gedacht und nicht
zu ende geführt hat das müssen wir jetzt
ausbaden und müssen eben schauen wie wir
das wieder auf einen vernünftigen weg
bringen und das umfeld in der baubranche
ist dafür alles andere als ideal
der wohnungsbau steht unter druck weil
fachkräfte fehlen und die preise für die
baumaterialien kräftig angezogen haben
das hat auch mein vorredner gesagt aber
die frage ist natürlich was ist die
lösung für das problem und die lösung
für das problem bei den fachkräften ist
vor allem zuwanderung
einwanderung mehr menschen in
deutschland in den arbeitsmarkt in
diesem bereich bringen und
qualifizierung der menschen denn alleine
250.000 offene stellen im handwerk und
in den nächsten fünf jahren werden
125.000 kleinere mittlere
handwerksbetriebe eine nachfolge suchen
und dafür brauchen wir eine lösung und
da freuen wir uns natürlich auf menschen
die nach deutschland kommen und hier für
uns in diesem bereich tätig werden
wollen dass die baukosten steigen das
wissen wir und es geht halt darum dass
wir in zukunft konsequent ressourcen
sparen ressourcen schonen und natürlich
auch konsequent aus den fossilen
energieträgern aussteigen und dazu muss
der wohnungssektor einen großen beitrag
leisten und deshalb ist für uns auch die
verschärfung der standards bei der
energetischen sanierung der richtige weg
wir wollen diese verstärkt an
nachhaltigkeit und der co2 einsparung
ausrichten
und wir werden auch in den neuen
haushaltsberatungen 2023 akzente setzen
denn wir haben es natürlich nicht
geschafft in sechs monaten alles
umzusetzen was wir uns vorgenommen haben
der koalitionsvertrag enthält viele
maßnahmen und vorhaben die wir auf den
weg bringen werden unter schwierige
umfeld zwingt uns heute mehr denn je
prioritäten zu setzen und zwar auf
nachfrage
richtung den schwerpunkt auf sanierung
und umnutzung legen auf aufstockung und
ausbau der schon vorhandenen bausubstanz
und wir müssen die potenziale des
seriellen und modularen bauens nutzen
das bauen schneller effektiver und
preisgünstiger machen und unsere bau
ministerin vor witz hat ja schon im
vorfeld gesagt es ist nicht sinnvoll und
schon gar kein ökologischer umgang mit
knappen ressourcen noch mehr
einfamilienhäuser auf der grünen wiese
außerhalb der städte zu bauen und
deswegen planen wir die neue wohn
gemeinnützigkeit um dauerhaft
bezahlbaren wohnraum zu schaffen und
auch die programme der
städtebauförderung werden wir auf hohem
niveau fortführen denn es geht darum
so bahne räume neu zu gestalten den
klimawandel und die klimaanpassung zu
machen und wir sehen wir haben einiges
auf den weg gebracht und für 2023 viel
vor für eine nachhaltige und
zukunftssichere politik vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion hat nun der kollege
daniel für ist das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen frau ministerin
wir haben ja viel einigkeit wenn man mal
die ofd außen vornimmt will ja wirklich
jeder dass die menschen gut leistbar
leben können und der bestand co2
neutrales und bei allen unkenrufen zum
trotz ist es gut dass wir bei diesen
gigantischen herausforderungen vor denen
das bauen des wohnen und der bestand
stehen neues bauministerium geschaffen
haben natürlich geht immer mehr liebe
csu und wir haben jetzt schon bewiesen
dass auf alle fälle mehr geht wenn ihr
nicht mit in der regierung sein wir
haben das bauen wir haben die
haushaltsmittel aufgestockt wir
investieren mehr in den sozialen
wohnungsbau es ist legitim dass die dass
die opposition sagt es kann immer mehr
sein da schließe ich mich ja sogar an
natürlich kann immer mehr sein aber im
rahmen des möglichen
in rahmen der mittel die ja schon fest
gebunden sind in milliarden-höhe haben
wir neue akzente gesetzt und für diesen
ersten historischen
haushalt des bauministeriums da kann die
ampel zu recht stolz sein das geht in
die richtige richtung aber
natürlich natürlich ist nach einem
halben jahr noch nicht alles perfekt
natürlich so nicht alle probleme gelöst
wir müssen die angebotslücke schließen
völlig ohne frage es ist ja es ist ja je
nach wissenschaftliche institute
schwankt die zahl an neuen wohnungen die
wir brauchen zwischen 400 bis 700.000
wohnungen im jahr das eine gigantische
aufgabe und diese angebotslücke werden
wir nur schließen können wenn wir die
bremsen lösen das bedeutet planungs
beschleunigung und die ampel hat gezeigt
was sie unter planungs beschleunigung
bei den lng terminals versteht das kann
eine blaupause dazu werden wir die
großen bedarf an neuen wohnungen
schützen ja ich weiß die csu freunde
ganz haft sagt also was ja ich bin ja
bereit zu diskutieren und zu reden und
ich schätze auch ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen bauen und wohnen aber immer nur
der seiten ruf mehr warum macht das
nicht kommt nicht mal vorliegt man vor
lebt hier mal hin was ihr konkret volt
start nur vor und da können wir mal
produkt im koalitionsvertrag abschreiben
lassen das ist dann auch schön den
können wir beraten also wir müssen die
angebotslücke schließen ohne zweifel und
da ist es sehr sehr gut dass wir in der
ampel und im koalitionsvertrag erkannt
haben der staat wird das alleine nicht
schaffen wir brauchen den privaten
sektor wir brauchen die kleinen
häuslebauer wir brauchen die
genossenschaften ja wir brauchen auch
den staatlichen städtischen den
kommunalen wohnungsbau es ist alles
richtig und deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir von kooperation konfrontation auf
kooperation was konfrontation im
wohnungsmarkt anrichtet das zeigt berlin
wirklich zur genüge und da ist dann
immer wieder realsatire
wenn ich die kollegin mey höre wie toll
ist alles sei berlin ist funktional und
der wohnungsmarkt in berlin ist
gescheitert
hier
also angebotslücke schließen planungs
beschleunigung noch an die biker die
baukosten rang es ist ja völlig zurecht
formuliert worden dass die baukosten uns
davonlaufen es wird immer teurer zu
bauen und da ist eine klare antwort
meine liebe im kölner das was die
letzten jahre nicht gemacht habt
bauforschung stärken bauforschung
stärken wir müssen das bbt ausbauen wir
müssen mehr in die forschung investieren
wir müssen auch das entwickelt des
seriell modularen bauen und sanieren
stärke des building information modeling
ist ein ganz zentraler baustein von der
digital planung über über die erstellung
bis hin zum betrieb des gebäudes
technologie ist einer der antworten um
die probleme am wohnungsmarkt zu lösen
was wir darüber hinaus ebenfalls
brauchen
es gibt genug flaschenhälse bei der
frage im wohnungsbau die frage ist
natürlich die kamen hier auch auf wo
bauen wir die neuen wohnungen und da bin
ich ja selber der meinung wir können
nicht alles auf der grünen wiese bauen
ich bin felsenfest davon überzeugt dass
wir bei der frage im neubau wegkommen
müssen vom bauland begriff hin zum bau
potenzial begriff wo können wir auch
stoppen wo können wir um widmen wo
kommen wir um bauen wo es eine brache wo
müssen wir vielleicht doch neubau oder
neues bauland entwickeln das ist eine
entscheidende frage um die knappheit des
baulands zu lösen indem wir ins boot
enzian gehen uns sachen trennen dass wir
immer alles auf der grünen wiese bauen
wollen
abschließend abschließend
die eigentumsquote
in deutschland für ein sowohl haben das
land ich empfinde es als beschämend
wir sind ganz ganz hinten in europa in
der eu und sie sogar
ganz ganz hinten es kann natürlich
streiten ob der letzte oder vorletzte ob
das ganz ganz hinten ist oder nicht kann
man darüber streiten dass die linke ist
jede button führt zeigt auch wie völlig
ergebnislose politik macht aber aber nur
in gedanken kurzzeitig zu machen wir
müssen die menschen zeigen bringen
eigentum schützt vor altersarmut nicht
nur die generationen die es erarbeitet
seiner generation darüber hinaus
eigentum führt zu einer fairen
vermögensverteilung und eigentum
stabilisiert ganze wohnviertel ganz
wohnbereiche deswegen ist
eigentumsförderung ein erklärtes starkes
ziel für 2023 wir kriegen nicht alles in
einem haushalt hin nicht alles in einem
jahr hin aber diese ampel ist für diese
legislaturperiode auf einem sehr sehr
guten weg ich freue mich auf alle
weiteren haushaltsdebatten vielen dank
mehr wohneigentum ist ein altes in
anführungszeichen thema der fdp auch
daniel fürst hat es hier noch mal
thematisiert die große frage ist
natürlich wie man diese eigentumsquote
steigern will denn geld ist nicht immer
so günstig wie im moment nächster redner
michael breilmann aus der unionsfraktion
wir haben ja gerade vom kollegen fest
einiges an zahlen gehört auch einiges
was man machen sollte ich frage mich nur
warum ihre ganzen vorschläge sich dann
nicht in diesem haushalt wiederfinden
das wundert mich an und wir haben gerade
gesprochen sie haben mehr für forschung
getan wenn ich mir jetzt hier das deckt
platz zum einzelplan 25 angucke
forschung untersuchung und ähnliches da
sehe ich eine kürzung von
59.000 eine kürzung also sie sollten
vielleicht einmal mit dem zahlenmaterial
richtig arbeiten unser haushälter markus
uhl hatte ein auge drauf
und wir beraten heute abschließend nicht
nur den ersten etat des neuen
bauministeriums
sondern damit auch die umsetzung eines
der zentralen versprechen dieser neuen
bundesregierung ein versprechen dass
olaf scholz oft sich marktplätzen in
deutschland gegeben hat
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr davon
100.000 sozialwohnungen und ich finde da
ist es nur fair und das sollten wir
heute auch noch mal deutlich machen
liefert haushaltsdebatte zu schauen ob
diese ziele und die haben sie sich
selber gegeben ob diese ziele erreicht
werden können und welche mittel sie
dafür auch haushaltspolitisch eingesetzt
haben und wenn wir uns dann die zahlen
und damit auch anspruch und wirklichkeit
dieser politik jetzt mal angucken und
auch die prognosen die aus der
baubranche aus dem baubereich kommen
dann finde ich schon seltsam mit einigen
ausnahmen selbstkritik bei der fdp ist
dabei die ampel vertreter feiern sich
aber hier in der mehrheit in dieser
debatte selbst ob ihre ansätze einzelne
ansätze aber die realität in diesem
lande die ist doch wirklich eine völlig
andere ab 2023 wird das maximum von
neubauwohnungen schätzungen zufolge bei
250.000 wohnungen die baubranche
wandlungs bereits jetzt für 2023 vor
weiterem gegenwind bauern verschiedenen
projekte oder stornieren sie sogar ganz
zudem verteuert sich mit anziehenden
kredit zinsen gerade die finanzierung
das ist alarmierend das zeigt aber auch
und das muss man hier heute mal
ansprechen sie werden ihre ziele
vermutlich nicht erreichen sie werden
verfehlt und wir brauchen
nein das freut uns nicht deswegen geben
wir auch vorschläge und dagegen auch
gleich noch drauf ein denn wir brauchen
haben sie zum wir brauchen einen
vernünftigen mix aus klugen
investitionen neuen freiraum
experimentierfelder auch im bereich
forschung & allrad system sowie stärkung
von eigeninitiativen verlässliche
förderbedingungen maßnahmen gegen
baukostensteigerungen baugrundstücke
zügig bereitstellen schnellere
planungsverfahren keine verschärfungen
mietrecht klimaschutz effizient an gegen